uh it being uh 1005 uh we're going to go
ahead and open this working group
session
uh the first uh bill that we're going to
hear is 1604
uh for for those of you who have thought
you might want to stay through the day
i'll give you a little bit of a preview
of coming attractions
because of the amendment there's two or
three
bills that no longer have a fiscal note
associated with them
and
because they no longer have a fiscal
note associated with them
finance doesn't really have
any jurisdiction
and in talking to the clerk today
there's a house rule i believe it's 31f
that says that if we have no fiscal
impact then we uh then the chair of
finance should just communicate that
uh we're returning the bills without
action and then the clerk will read that
on the house floor
and there won't need to be a re-vote
because it's already been voted so
so some of the bills are like that and
but most of them are not
so with that
we'll start with
representative
cushman was the prime sponsor and
although this is a working group
i i know that she's
thoughtfully prepared an amendment and
i'd i'd like to give her an opportunity
and then
for the clerk just state your name and
all
thank you mr chairman
my name is leah cushman i represent ware
and deering in hillsborough district 2.
i have an amendment here that eliminates
the conscientious object
exemption
and
just leaves religious exemption with a
simple statement and i think that'll
alleviate as much as i believe that we
should
fight the federal government on this
and you know protect the rights of our
health care workers
state health care workers i
i believe this will do
what i wanted the bill to do really
besides for a very small number of
people
so if you have copies of your amendment
could you distribute them and then while
that's happening
i'll ask you if um
if if your amendment and if you don't
know i might ask mr ripple for his
interpretation uh if your amendment
uh
is
i i think the effect of your amendment
is it deletes
a medical exemption
altogether
and i don't think that's your intent i
just don't want to accidentally make a
mistake with the way the amendment is
phrased
um so
it doesn't delete so under the rule it
would just default to whatever cms's
rule is regarding medical exemptions it
doesn't mention it at all it just
mentions
that for religious exemptions they have
to just accept a simple statement and
the whole reason is that these have
turned into religious inquisition so
that's what we're trying to avoid by
allowing a simple statement to be
granted
right i i would avoid the term religious
inquisition and just simply say that
employers
are not set up in their hr departments
to have somebody qualified to evaluate
another individual's religious beliefs
and because they lack the qualification
they shouldn't have the authority to
have an opinion on somebody else's
religious beliefs so i like i like what
you've done with the religious amendment
part of this
um and
um
i i just want to make sure that we don't
inadvertently remove the medical
exemption
and so mr ripple is
very busy um
so mr ripple while you were doing that
did you did you hear what i was saying
about i i i like the religious exemption
part of representative cushman's
amendment but i
but in the other amendment that she
drafted on my behalf or had drafted on
my behalf we talked to the medical
exemption part and
i get representative cushman's point
that there's too much in this
because if cms changes their rules then
our law is out of sync and so it should
just basically be referring to the cms
somehow
so what what what are your thoughts if
her language only deals
with
the religious um uh exemption part does
do you think it inadvertently
removes
the medical and then
similarly
uh does it also delete the con
conscience or conscientious
uh exemption because that should be
deleted um it does delete both of those
leaving only the religious exemption i
think if you wanted to include a medical
exemption but without as much detail as
in your amendment you could probably
add medical back with some general
reference to as defined by the centers
for medicare and medicaid services and
so that way if their definition or their
requirements changed it would still be
included in state law
all right that sounds rational would you
would you
be bothered if we amended your amendment
not at all nope that sounds that sounds
like it makes sense to me okay we have a
i think that's representative kenner can
hear but that's okay
i'm sorry i'm just joking i'm just
joking
but um yeah i think it's important that
we
not take out the medical exemption
because that's actually one of the most
important exemptions that's there the
important part and i'll just distribute
this is the requirements for the
exemptions are set by the federal
government by cms and we have to follow
those the supremacy clause states that
clearly
and they have reiterated that we must
follow their requirements not the states
can't make their own rules for it
and my colleague representative cushman
knows that she and i thought about the
conscientious thing and i appreciate you
taking that out
the other issue
um is could we just do one at a time
because
one issue at a time yeah i mean well
it's back to the medical um so i don't
think i think we somehow need to still
acknowledge that we want to make sure
that that doesn't disappear and i do
agree it needs to just default to their
rules if we can't start putting it into
statute what the rules ought to be
because those could change
so let me ask you a question about it
please um in the cms guidelines do they
have criteria for how a religious
because
uh
the right side column it lists the
religious exemption
uh all right so
um
i'll get to you in just a second
representative rogers so so just for the
audience following this uh the
requirements for the basics for a
religious exemption is
facilities must develop a process for
permitting staff to request a religious
exemption on that criteria i think
representative cushman's religious
and then the second one is facilities
must ensure
all requests for religious exemptions
are documented and evaluated in
accordance with applicable law and as
part of the facility's policies and
procedures
i don't know all of the federal law in
this space when i did my homework uh
over the weekend
um
i didn't get anyone pushing back on me
that
the cushman statement would conflict
yeah that was actually my second concern
and that is it just says that if you
write it it's automatically requested if
you request it
this the cms rules do say that the
facility must ensure that they're
documented and evaluated and that still
remains in conflict
if the if they're evaluated
and they're directed to
shall accept but i i don't know i i'm
enough of a word weasel that i would say
that would qualify as an evaluation i've
received documentation it's properly
filled out i know who the employee is
uh so i've evaluated that this is a good
and accurate document and we're
accepting it so so i think under the
word evaluation this would qualify uh go
ahead
i would respectfully disagree documented
is exactly what you said we have a form
we know the person is that's a
documentation evaluated means you look
at is it been a clear and consistent
belief or just what they usually try to
apply
or just like any other aspect of
evaluation that means actually looking
at it and critically analyzing whether
it is accurate or not that's evaluation
documentation is just the piece of paper
so it's that second part of the word in
the cms rules and evaluated in
accordance if applicable federal law
that i think
i think we just need to default to the
federal law just as we would for for
medical we should default to the
the federal law or regulation i'm sorry
uh for the religious as well
all right so
so we have a difference of opinion and
i'll come to you in just a second
representative rogers uh
um
we have a difference of opinion i if if
we're allowed
i i just firmly believe that there's no
one in an employer
situation
that is qualified to evaluate another
individual's religious beliefs
and because they lack qualification i
cannot
in good conscience
delegate to them the authority of ruling
on
uh whether or not somebody's religious
beliefs are sufficient for for them
so
so uh that's kind of where i am
yeah um representative knark is is new
to sitting in here so
he might not be familiar with it but my
understanding is that these bills have
passed the policy committee they've
passed the floor on policy and we are
the second committee but we're supposed
to be looking at the financial end of it
only and not redoing the policy
one of the biggest complaints that many
people have traditionally always had is
when finance sticks its nose into policy
after it's been decided not only by the
committee but by a vote on the floor so
i guess i'm concerned as to why
we are re-debating policy and not just
um the reason for that
is and that's you have a very fair point
and i but i think what we're
trying to deal with
is that uh as currently written 1604
puts some of the federal funding at risk
and so we want to shave off anything
that would create the risk
while still
having a
strong statement
on the part of the state of new
hampshire
and and representative cushman as the
primary sponsor is is is in a fairly
good position to to represent what what
we've done already on the policy side so
follow up i just i'm very concerned that
we're we're delving very dangerously
close to re-debating policy that's been
debated um representative knuck just
just referred to it um disagreement that
he had with representative cushman in
the policy committee and if the policy
committee decided one way i understand
what you're saying if it has
a loss of federal funds but i think
we're dangerously close and we need to
be very careful not to cross that line
all right so
so i don't
i
i understand your point i i don't i
wouldn't apply the word dangerous to
what we're doing uh we're having a
conversation so
what i what i would like to do
on this mr ripple is is if you could
take
the cushman amendment
and then
make sure that we have sufficient
wording in the in a new draft of the
amendment so that we don't accidentally
leave out the medical exemption
and it would be great is there anyone in
the room who's qualified to talk about
the full body of federal law relative to
religious exemptions
i don't i don't think there is
um
and then since we're going to end up
having to talk about this on the 21st
because we'll look at the amendment then
um if if we could um shake the tree of
of the state a little bit see if we
could get an opinion on the whether or
not the religious exemption as written
in the amendment if that would conflict
is that is that okay yup sure i can try
to do that
all right so represent wallner
[Music]
this is
a question for you do we have someone in
the room who can talk to us about the
uh all right um
is there anyone in the audience
that wants to talk about the potential
loss of cms funding if if we do these
exemptions wrong
yes come on up
good morning my name is joe christie i'm
the chief financial officer for new
hampshire hospital and glencliff home
i'm happy to answer any questions you
can answer laura could you repeat your
last name slowly for me uh christie
c-a-r-i-s-t-i
okay so
if you could since you're steeped in
this
um
what what we
what i want the finance committee to do
is to avoid
running into a conflict with with
federal law or cms rules
nevertheless i would like to
have a path along that boundary
to where
we're not delegating to an employer
the the duty
to evaluate somebody's religious beliefs
that's just outside of their purview um
so so could you
uh i don't know if you've considered
this amendment yet
but if you were to just look at
um
where did i put representative cushman's
amendment
if if you could just read from like line
5 down to 12 of amendment 108.2 do you
have that
i do yep okay uh i'll give you like a
minute to really look at it and think
about it
yeah i've actually i was reading it in
the in the back of the room
i think and for the religious exemptions
um the
the guidance that representative knight
provided is actually
fairly consistent with what we've seen
from the guidance that we've received as
a facility there's not a lot of detail
in the cms rules relative to the
religious exemption process
i think i i do share that same kind of
thought that representative khanurkh had
that
there does need to be some sort of
evaluation process but cms doesn't
define what that process is
so in that regard i'm unsure um
and i don't think there's guidance out
there that would answer that question
one way or the other right now
so if um if our if the state of new
hampshire took the position that the
evaluation was satisfied
uh by the employer's receipt of the
documentation and validation that it
came from
one of their employees and was submitted
in accordance with their process
that
to me is an evaluation of yes we have
good documentation
and therefore the word evaluation would
be satisfied do you
[Music]
do you believe that to just be a bad
interpretation or just a different
interpretation
i think i just don't know um there's not
enough guidance that supports that
argument one way or the other from what
i've seen
okay
great uh so we've got an amendment that
we'll look at on monday the 21st and if
you wouldn't mind
delving into that and then mr ripple if
you could find whoever is our expert on
federal law on this it'd be great to get
an opinion
okay
uh there's another
hold on what was your title
chief financial officer of new hampshire
hospital and glencliff home thank you
representative walner
thank you
do you think the way the bill is written
now the way it came from health and
human services does it still put us in
jeopardy of losing
federal funds or
what federal funds might be put in
question
as it came from the house or as this
amendment would read
oh well as it came from the house i'd
like to know that and then
with the amendment
as it came from the house yes i believe
it would because it does include
a conscience a conscientious
exemption which is not allowed within
the cms
guidance relative to the coven 19
vaccine mandate um and then i believe
the medical exemptions are um
the amount of information required in in
the current house bill 1604 for a
medical exemption is less than what cms
requires
thank you
all right a follow-up to that though is
if we're taking out the conscientious uh
exemption of just removing it and if
we're
leaving the medical uh with a with the
right nub on it so that it hooks into
whatever the cms guidelines are
then that takes care of your two
big rocks your two big concerns
that is correct and then on the
religious one i as i've said i just
don't know um there's not enough enough
guidance out there
okay so we have a week to work on the
don't know part so that's that's fine
um
are there any other questions from the
committee
is there anyone in the oh go ahead
doctor excuse me i force a habit
representative kenner
yes i i appreciate the comments that
were made but i think it and and i do
appreciate that we are not supposed to
discuss the policy but the
impact fiscal impact is
directly influenced by the policy that
was generated by this which does place
us in conflict the other piece is not
just
the impact on the state
but the impact on the counties and any
other nursing homes that take medicaid
uh reimbursement which is essentially
almost all of them all
five out of there's seven out of ninety
private homes in the state that don't
take medicaid but most do and all the
county homes do
because they will also face the same
thing and the estimated amount of
medicaid dollars that flow to this state
just the federal share
for just the nursing homes i think is
around 200 million dollars so that would
be in addition to the losses would occur
with glenn cliff and the new hampshire
hospital so it's a sizable risk of loss
if we do not comply with the rules which
as it comes out of the house it clearly
does not comply with the rules
so would you believe that we're in
violent agreement that this committee
will do nothing to put at risk the
federal funding around cms
i would hope so
because i don't think we're prepared to
backfill 200 million dollars uh no but i
think we're being very careful to to not
do that while recognizing that new
hampshire has a different
has its own perspective on how to
employers should be evaluating religious
exemptions
all right
thank you chairman edwards my name is
kate horgan i represent the new
hampshire association of counties i just
wanted to bring a line nine to the
so it says employees contractors
patients visitors or students
so are you talking about line nine of
the cushman amazon amendment all right
i'm ready okay so we are only
responsible for holding vaccine
information for our employees
not for visitors not for patients
students i can kind of see because we
have student nurses in but i would hate
for this
to require us to hold all that extra
information if we don't need to so i
think
if you took out contractors patients and
visitors that would make it a better
amendment because we aren't asking for
that anyway
it's not part of the cms requirement
miss ripple do you have that
all right so he's drafting the amendment
i think that's a good guidance thank you
very much
um okay last call
representative
leon
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
highlight one point from that last
statement it does not require the
facilities to take those exemptions it
says shall upon request
i believe that this would be a
protection should the rules change to
include patients visitors or those
students who are undergoing part of
their clinical rotation
so i would like to see if we can
understand if that shall upon request
doesn't put a burden unless
these these requirements are placed upon
miss ripple did you write it down to
where we're going to delete the
reference to contractors patients and
visitors and leave in students
yes my initial thought was that you
does that meet your uh your observation
uh my observation is that it says um
upon request and i'm not sure why they
would need to request an exemption
unless they were required to provide
proof of vaccination um i i see that as
um
i just see that as something that isn't
so the facilities are generally not
attempting
i can clarify that sir all right
um in the guidelines because again what
we're trying to do is meet the
guidelines
vaccination requirements apply to all
eligible staff current and new working
at a facility
including
facility employees licensed
practitioners students
trainees volunteers
contracted staff so they those groups
are included not visitors but those
groups are included in the cms mandate
so we should not be excluding them from
this amendment if we're going to try to
match i think we could also again just
default to cms rules in this that might
be safer in case
and this is difficult with writing
legislation we often just refer
to a cfr or something like that
where
if it changes we still have the proper
statutory reference or cfr reference
here we're trying to parse it and if it
changes then we could become out of
compliance because the rules changed i
don't know that they're going to change
the rules
but
that's an important piece
when we're talking about these
categories who are eligible to request a
religious exemption can we just simply
uh write that in a more generic way that
anyone
that
falls under the guidance of the cms
guidelines
would be covered
i think you can do that i haven't seen
the cms rule in question so i don't know
how it currently reads but i don't see
why you couldn't
i can i can provide that if give me your
email okay
yeah i'll send you an email so you'll
have you'll have mine
okay
so good good good feedback good input
thank you do you have anything else um
so
uh last call on 1604 is there one anyone
in the room that still has something uh
represent representative kenner uh two
things one the first one is simply what
have we decided to do about the medical
piece and the second one is you have
this other amendment are we going to
um no i'm not going to introduce the
other amendment um and and i
i i think what we've done is we've
directed mr ripple
to use the cushman amendment as
a platform and then to make sure
that we have the proper reference to the
cms rules on medical exemptions so that
the amendment that we consider
one week from today
will will have
everything that we need is the hope you
know i think the simplest conclusion
would be to still keep all of
representative cushman's amendment which
starts
but on line three just to simply sorry
sorry line eight just to simply say the
rule shall default to the cms guidelines
period because also this is written not
just for this current
uh guideline but it's subject to a valid
and in line seven a valid and
enforceable medicare medicaid condition
of participation there may be something
that comes down the pike later and our
legislature our statutes need to be
flexible and nimble to anticipate other
things and not be always focused on for
example in this case just covered 19
stuff
so to make it nimble if we just say
um you know anything that comes down the
line is versus lines seven and eight and
it says rules shall default to the cms
rules period we don't have to do a whole
lot of parsing it's done
i think we have an obligation to protect
the rights of new hampshire citizens and
i i i want there to be clarity that the
new hampshire position is is
is what it is and that is
employers are simply not qualified to
evaluate a religious exemption and
therefore
the best i think they should do or the
most they should do
is to properly process the paperwork
and if they need to internally reassign
someone because of their concerns about
a possible transmission of infection
they can do that but i i don't want them
about
evaluating uh somebody's personally held
religious belief so so i think that's
the amendment we're going to see next
week and uh
and then we can have another discussion
your mic is still on just
just a warrant just to warn you people
have said things with mike's hot mic so
oh okay last call on 1604
that closes 1604 uh the next bill up
will be
1608.
uh representative prout said he might be
here is there anyone standing in for
is that you represent leon
okay and and before i get you too fired
up i want to consult with mr ripple is
this one of the
bills that has no fiscal impact now yes
okay so uh i got you you're moving for
no reason because if there's no fiscal
impact um
i i would like the committee
to
pass us back to the finance committee
and
recommended the chair that she informed
the clerk that we you know we don't have
jurisdiction under rule 41f we should be
returning
this without action from the finance
committee
do you have a problem with that i have
no problem with that representative
connerk and representative walner
i disagree about no fiscal impact it's
vastly diminished
because the initial thing had this
massive amount of contact campaigns with
mail and emails and all kinds of things
and that led to the very large
fiscal responsibility
the new the amendment massively
decreases this because it just says the
department shall execute a public
information campaign to inform
individuals that data was collected
during that state of emergency
that's vastly less and that's actually
why we put this amendment in was to
decrease the cost
but i find it hard to believe the
department's going to be able to do a
massive public
outreach campaign with no funds
so this is one of the things where
i rely on the lba to be the impartial
unbiased umpire calling the balls and
the strikes and so
i'll just ask again of mr ripple who
represents the unbiased lba
is there a fiscal note now after the
amendment or is there a determination of
no fiscal impact there is a fiscal note
but it reads that there's no fiscal
impact and that was based on
the response that we received from hhs
and their position i believe was
that
they could accomplish the objectives of
this bill within their existing budget
which we typically reflect as no fiscal
impact
absolutely that's great i'm happy to
all right so can i interpret that to
to mean that you're you're you're fine
with us
re-referring this back to finance
representative kenner oh yes if there's
no if they can handle with the current
budget then it's perfectly fine because
we like the
we
we were 19 to zero favoring the policy
we just we were trying to cut the cost
and it looks like we managed thank you
uh representative erf did you have a
question
well i'm just wondering why we can't
refer back
as otp because clearly
the folks are not aware of this
change i mean the change in the note i
in other words the fact that it's no
cost might change everybody's
interpretation of how to look at this
bill
so i might refer back with an otp not
if
if the fiscal note says there's no
fiscal impact
based on my conversation with the clerk
it's fairly clear that we should just
have
uh ask the chairman of the finance
committee to send this
back because there is no fiscal impact
i understand what you're saying but we
should clarify that that's a change
from the way the bill was viewed when it
passed the house because that
fiscal note stating no impact
was not available to the house when they
considered the bill they were looking at
eight million dollar cost which i agree
all right so i'm just trying to apply
some common sense i think i learned in
nebraska which is uh
that if they approve this policy with an
eight million dollar price tag
they'll love it when it doesn't cost
anything and given the number of bills
that we have to hear and vote on before
we we get everything to the senate i i'd
keep that i'd rather keep this light
representative walner
thank you chairman
i don't remember us using this process
in the past
where we
if it if we determined it had no
physical impact
usually we proceeded on to
and ought to pass on the floor i mean
that was usually the way we did it i
don't remember this process
so i just need to
sort of refresh my
memory of that with the clerk i don't
maybe someone else who's been on on
finance with me for
in the past remembers how
using that but i don't remember us using
that in the past
i i'd welcome you to talk to the clerk
my memory is horrible but i i just
talked to him this morning okay and i
think i can remember that long no i'm
sure i'm sure that um
that's what the clerk said i just didn't
remember us
years in the past
using that process and i trust your
experience and background and and all
this your judgment so so please do uh
because
we don't have to turn this back to the
committee until next monday okay great
thank you represent representative
kenner
you got it um actually
we did not happily approve this with an
8 million expenditure that's why we
amended it
we amended it to get rid of that 8
million expenditure that was the whole
point of the amendment well not the
whole point but a lot of it and as a
historical point for this particular
committee you'll appreciate that neil
kirk came in actually to testify on this
and um for the second time this year he
and i had come up to the precise same
conclusion on our own i had written my
usual thing that i wrote on sunday
before the hearing
and that's precisely what he
suggested which is very expensive we
just need a public outreach thing and he
and i came to the same conclusion the
committee did as well and we did that to
okay
so i'm not sensing any opposition to us
holding on to this while representative
walner has an opportunity to talk to the
clerk and we can revalidate um just
passing this back to the finance chair
is that i see you saying yes yes thank
you
uh is there any thank you is there any
uh anyone in the room that wants to talk
to 1608
all right
we'll close that
or
postpone it again still for a week
at this point
um
this one
ends up um there's an amendment
if you look if you look at um
the bill is amended with 0.0577
which is the one that you had handed to
you
you'll see
that this on line 20 of page 3
cites the labor grade at
as a 32
with a sum of 254 000 appropriated
as i understand that this has been
getting reworked in the department
and that labor grade
went through an hr evaluation process
and they determined it should be a grade
which drops
the sum from 254 to 138
000 or so it's a little less than that
and
and we end up picking up some federal
money to help us pay for this is yet
another
all right and so so we're going to look
at
um
what mr ripple is now handing out uh
oh wait i'm still on line 20. so in
other words the fiscal note just got
better
um is that what you're up to talk to
yes good morning
okay
just introduce yourself for the record i
sure will and ernie gillen g-i-l-l-a-n
i'm the deputy director for information
services at department health and human
services
so tell us what you want to tell us
please uh just here to support what
you're saying nancy are any questions
about the
the financial differences
the labor grade 30 was a correction for
that position the business system
analyst two
is a library 30 and that came at a
if it was all general funds it would be
228 000 but there is federal assistance
in there that lowers that cost
okay does it lower down to around 138
000 in general funds i i don't want to
have misrepresented it
yeah 37 480 that's correct all right
okay uh why don't you why don't you sit
there uh for a moment are there any
questions about that uh that
i'm i'm not seeing any from the
committee so so have you seen
the amendment
what this amendment does
is as i as i reread the bill
it seemed to me that it would be a fair
interpretation
if somebody thought they could write one
privacy impact
assessment which is the risk mitigation
form that that they could write one and
then it would automatically cover all of
the i.t systems
in the department
the
purpose of the privacy impact assessment
is is each it system is to be evaluated
on its own and completely and
comprehensively so so the clarifying
language
is meant to
just make sure that people understand
that there's
one for one privacy impact assessment
per it system
it reads for each information technology
system that contains personal
information the department shall conduct
a written risk assessment and mitigation
remediation plan in the form of a
privacy impact assessment
so that that's just clarifying what our
intent always was
do you do you have anything to say to
that did you did you ever interpret it
that one pia would handle you know like
17 systems
well we understand it exactly how you
just explained it one for each
individual system
okay
so uh let me ask mr ripple a question
um
given that the the department has
identified that they could do this with
a grade 30
do you think
that we need an amendment to change the
32 to a 30 or or just leave that
component in the in the bill as is
i would suggest changing it from 32 to
30 but i don't if you wanted to vote on
this today i don't think you would need
an amendment in front of you you could
all right
thank you for that um
i i don't want to take a vote on this
because uh
i promise representative weiler i'd wait
for him and he's at another uh meeting
somewhere so
um
[Music]
with this i think if there's no one else
is there anyone else in the room that
wants to testify on 1662
are there any questions from the
committee
yes representative knight yes i just had
one question we talked about the two new
employees
but there were some other issues in the
fiscal note that i never did understand
where that money would be coming from
and that's at least the fiscal note when
it came through our department sorry our
committee
and that was on the second page of the
fiscal note it talks about another four
hundred and seventy thousand dollars for
uh supporting analysis and assessments
of symptom systems and a chief privacy
offer officer at around 200k and so on
i'm just confused are those
we aren't discussing those in detail or
is that because that's not the point of
discussion here no no um
you raise a point that should have been
made up front is that the fiscal note
that's attached
was based on the bill as introduced and
then we amended
some major items out yeah and so
major chunks of the fiscal note got
pulled out
to really now the fiscal note will be
limited to the new employees that's my
understanding
but that the lba has not yet produced a
new fiscal note
is is that correct representative ripple
or how is it incorrect
that is correct uh we haven't put out a
new fiscal note yet but i do have the
information that the department provided
to us which shows the net cost of around
130 000 per year that you mentioned
previously i can hand this out if you
want
would you like a copy of that
representative conner
no i trust you i just i just wanted
this was just never resolved for me
earlier or at this point thank you
all right
um
are there any other questions on this
is there anyone else here in the room
[Music]
so i'm just thinking about the proper
motion here i think i think what we're
going to do is uh allow
the lba to generate another minor
amendment
uh to change the labor grade
from 32 to 30
to go ahead and add
does anybody
oppose adding
amendment
1075 which clarifies the language for
for each
now i'm not seeing any
so we'll go ahead and incorporate that
and then next monday we can reconsider
um
1662.
and with that
the the next bill that we have up is uh
and um i i had i had budgeted a couple
hours for us to get through these three
bills and we did it in 50 minutes
so um but because we're in the house
calendar at one o'clock we have to
recess to one o'clock at which point
we'll start 1609 representative rogers i
was just going to point out i know that
there's some people coming specifically
for that
and they won't be here until once
which is why i scheduled it at a
specific time to make sure that people
didn't have to sit here for hours and
hours yeah so we're gonna
we're gonna start at uh one o'clock and
with that um
this hearing is on recess until one
o'clock
if you have a chance representative
edwards can i have a short conversation
okay
you
foreign
representative canark
okay i have uh
i'm going to bring the committee out of
recess
we're going to
begin the afternoon
on
hb 1609
just for an informational note to
the members of the committee
division one asked us to take over hb
1647 relative to the calculation of
child support
so
i'm going to have this added to our
monday schedule so that we can hear it
but
but if you want to start getting up to
speed on 1647
okay
so
hb 1609
do we have
i think that we had
representative wolf who's going to start
talking to us representative wolf do you
want to
start us off just tell give us your name
there's no pink card but give us your
name
and
contact information or whatever to for
our
secretary just
hold this down
oh there it is thank you thank you mr
chairman and thank you members of the
i think
that i want to
begin by saying i'm not a doctor i don't
know any
a lot of these medical terms
i know
a daughter that i have very very well
who's going through a troubled pregnancy
right now
it gives me a new insight into what is
and i understand that there are some
issues on 1609
when i brought it forward
it was basically
to allow
certain exceptions
an exception for rape
an exception for incest
and i understand
from my discussions that people
have become mired in the fact that there
may be
a huge number of people that are going
to use rape or incest for an excuse to
get an abortion
i don't believe anybody will be doing
that
but there are ways to eliminate those
possibilities
i think this bill is a good bill but it
may need some
modifications
and i am willing as a sponsor
to
propose those to work with you to amend
it
i'm most concerned
about
the health
safety of the mother
and
the
fetus
and in that regard
i think there should be some changes
made
after
working on this bill for almost six
months
i would keep the 24-week ban on
abortions
that's a reasonable number
and i'm not looking to change it
i am looking
to eliminate the exception
to have rape and incest
as
a reason for abortion after the 24 week
period
so we could eliminate those two
problems
but what i would
really
want to see happen
is that an abortion at any time
would be allowed
for the health
and life
of the mother
i would also want
an abortion allowed for fetal abnormal
no
you know what i'm trying to say
anomalies
thank you
representatives
should be
eliminated
again but at 24 weeks it comes back in
i think
that any
physician
that is performing
an abortion
after or close to 24 weeks
should have a penalty if they haven't
i'm not really
in favor of a criminal penalty i could
live with a civil penalty and maybe even
a loss of license those are important
things
so what i am saying here is
that
i would be willing
and desirous
of working with you
to
modify
this bill in a way that it becomes
acceptable to me it's critical
it's critical
that we protect
women
facing death
because of a pregnancy
or having to carry a fetus
to term
and
i hope that you people will not be
making a medical decision
for somebody who should be making a
decision
between
herself
her spouse and her doctor and possibly
her
um priest
so without getting into a lot of details
that's the summit substance i think that
the bill should be
modified but it should be passed
so so let me contextualize where where i
think we're at
um
i i think this committee
needs to be done with 1609
next week we have next week monday the
21st on the calendar
so if there is an amendment for us to
consider
we would need to see that in the next
couple of days and so that we can think
about it we can consult with others
and we can roll in here on the 21st
prepared to
give a recommendation to the full
finance committee
so so so that's that's part of the
context
uh the other context to share with you
to be to be fair now with you
is that
um
the language that got adopted into hb2
was
an essential part
set of agreements that were necessary
for us to get the votes to pass the
budget
and if we
got
1609 which is the language used by
people who
are
like what's in our law now they consider
this an attempt to gut the bill
um
we would need to do it in a way in which
we would have we would be preserving in
my opinion we need to preserve
the integrity of the promises that have
been made to the people who voted for
this
because we're only 15 months away from a
new budget new set of agreements
and if we burn
the bridges of our credibility
it'll be just that much more difficult
in the future to come to
um budget resolution
so
so i would i would want
to to entertain an amendment that you
may want to put forward representative
wolf
i'd ask you to try to
get
help
to get it in the next
48 hours 72 hours
and and i have i have some questions for
you just to clarify um
what i think you're saying yes sir go
ahead
i'd like to just respond to
your comment about commitments that were
made
i remember we were down in the sports
complex down there in bedford when the
and there were several reps that came up
and the governor
and they said to me
we'd like you to vote for the bill
and we'll
meet you afterwards
to work out some of these things that
were troubling to you
i knew
that
nothing about any
and now i sit here
and find out that a deal was made
and i have to tell you
that my credibility feels pretty short
because i would have voted against that
budget if i knew we weren't going to be
able to
modify
to some degree i'm not talking about
gutting the bill i'm talking about
after 24 weeks
for fetal
abnormalities incompatible with life
i'm talking about
a situation
that affects the mother the health and
life of the mother after 24 weeks
i'm talking about eliminating the
ultrasound up to approximately 24 weeks
so
i am and i'm leaving the penalties in to
a degree so i'm not gutting the bill
i'm making it a living bill that the
state of new hampshire can be proud of
having
okay i i just would want to point out
that the word deal uh sounds like a a
little bit of a pejorative there have
been agreements made i guess it's fair
to call them deals but
it's sort of a a hot button word i think
in this context uh good faith
discussions and agreements were made yes
you grew those deals sure if you want to
if
if there's an attempt to cast this in
more political terms but
um okay so i do want to go through your
checklist to share some concerns with
you um
so
uh
oh i just ask once again
um how this deals with the fiscal policy
um the various
amendments that you're talking about um
as i stated this morning i thought that
we were to deal with fiscal policy on
bills that come to us as a second
committee and not change the policy that
the policy committee agreed so
okay so representative rogers
i think
our ability to talk about the policy in
this case comes from the fact that this
got this issue was embedded in to the
hb2
and it was done so with a lot of
agreements in place
and
if finance were to be part of a process
to substantially change what went into
hb2
i think that would call into
doubt
the credibility of the finance committee
and and harm our ability to
have
budgets agreed to in the future
so i i think this is almost an
existential issue to our ability to get
the next budget in place
the reason i'm wanting to talk to
representative wolf have have this
committee talk to him
is because i think
that there may be some room for us
to
some of the issues he's he's raising
in a way in which we're really not
violating the fundamental principles and
agreements that we
came to in june
so so i'd like to go through and have a
conversation with representative wolf on
some of these issues so that we can
help him with an amendment
do you have a follow-up to that
representative rogers
no i think i've made my point and i
still agree with my point but i
accept what you said thank you
all right thank you
so
fetal anomaly
um that's incompatible with life let's
talk about that for a second
i i think
the concern
about adding that
is that
one it would
depend on
a diagnosis of of an obstetrician
and
oftentimes a diagnosis during a
pregnancy about the future health of the
baby
is is it is not accurate and
um and because that's just
natural human behavior because it's a
difficult situation to come up with the
diagnosis
um
it may be the case that we would want to
require
an autopsy or something to confirm
whether or not the diagnosis was
valid whether it was correct
okay um
i'm just throwing some thoughts at you
yeah
excuse me for
my facial experience no no that's fine
this is why
an autopsy would be a little bit late i
think
well on the fetus it would be able to
to confirm the diagnosis perhaps but
perhaps again again i'm not a provider
like you and and i i liked your facial
expression this is why we meet in public
is because there's more to communication
than just a zoom meeting so
you know
non-verbal communication counts
okay so um the other concern around
fetal anomalies
is that
uh the definition
of incompatible with life is not at all
clear
so if somebody
uh
diagnosed the baby
um
as having down syndrome for example
you know i'd want to know if that would
count
as a fetal anomaly incompatible with
life or not
and if it didn't
i'd want to see a definition
that we could be confident in
that would would rule out those kinds of
things that make life difficult
but
go ahead go ahead you can respond to
that because and then i'll hit the other
bullets too i'll try i'm not a doctor
i see we have one over there that may be
able to help us but
i don't think that down syndrome is
incompatible with life
i have a wonderful doctor
who has a child had a has a child who's
now grown up she's
how old is my son 36
she had down syndrome
they did not abort
she had a healthy birth but she had down
syndrome so i don't consider that
incompatible with life
what i'm talking about are those
situations
where medically they will tell you if
the child has this chromosomal their
life expectancy
may be
so short that they don't survive out of
the womb
and
they may be three to four days
outside of the womb
but the key question here
is
is it up to me
to decide is it up to you to decide
whether this child
should live or be allowed to die or
survive
by the mother's actions or non-actions
so i don't think that i or you or any of
us in this room should be making that
decision
somebody comes up and a chromosome test
shows that they're not going to make it
that is the mother
the father
and
again possibly the clergy so that's
that's where i'm coming from there are
definitions i mean somebody told me
about something called
uh
can we go to dr conner for dr
representative conner for a moment
because he may be able to help us out
with a definitional issue
this is precisely why we should not be
legislating the practice of medicine
which is what this bill of all the
original did
and what representative wolf was trying
to get it back to the doctor and the
patient to make a decision
based on our best science
it is correct doctors are not always
perfect
i had errors we all do but we do the
best we can and these can be very
confusing i don't think there's a single
practitioner who would say down syndrome
is a fatal fetal anomaly if it isn't
there are a few things that may shorten
the life a bit where we're talking about
decades
uh severe chondroid dystrophies are ones
where the bones simply don't form right
the chest can't support respiration as
soon as you're born you're going to die
within a very short time
and encephalitis which most of us became
familiar with when zika came around
where the that was just actually
microcephaly banana encephalitis where
there is no brain
and i mean none and as a result it's not
going to live the comment was made about
chromosomal abnormalities we have to be
a bit careful currently on the market
there are a whole bunch of companies
pushing
testing
for chromosomal deletions and the false
positive rate exceeds
the true positive rate
but these are rare
people who end up with a diagnosis of
this that are going to consider
termination get into very specific
high-quality obstetrical high-risk
obstetrical practices such as dartmouth
and i think elliott
at that point they're not going to rely
on some simple over-the-counter test
that gets done they're going to do a lot
more work to try to really sort out
what's going on some of them can be
quite obvious
uh with repeated ultrasounds to look at
the development
some of them can be really quite
clear-cut
chromosomal abnormalities but those are
usually not going to be done on just a
blood draw which is what these current
things are that are not very reliable
they would go through a process of
making sure that the diagnosis is
correct
but the bottom line is that's medicine
and there's a lot of things in medicine
that we don't define with absolute
precision because there's a gradation
and we have to make a decision
whether that
fetus may survive for one hour or may
survive for one week
you know we could try to set something
arbitrary it's like we put people in
hospice we often say it's supposed to be
a life expectancy less than six weeks
well sometimes it lasts eight weeks but
that doesn't mean that we were in error
we did the best we could the key is to
leave the practice of medicine
in medicine
thank you um and
i don't know if you'll be surprised but
but you and i actually share a great
deal of agreement on this i i don't want
the legislature practicing medicine
that's why we have smart people going to
med school
but but what we've done
i think
in the essence of this 24 week
period
is to recognize the state's interest
in protecting the constitutional rights
of of a human after 24 weeks
we've declared that person a human
and
that person then is entitled to the same
defenses that any human would be uh
to make a avail to themselves
but the state even has a greater duty
because these are
innocents that are unable to protect
themselves and so the state interest in
protecting that life
put
pushes us a little bit into that
envelope
and
i i do agree with you and i agree with
representative wolf
that
um
if we if we there was a fetal anomaly
that is incompatible with life
i'd i'd be open to
adding that to the reasons why you could
have an abortion after 24 weeks i i
think it's
it's just
wrong to insist that a a mom carry a
baby
longer just knowing that it's probably
terminal
i just um
because i'm a little cynical when it
comes to the motives of people who make
their profession on
abortion
i don't have a great deal of trust
for them
so i i just would want to try
and if i'm asking you to help me out on
this is if there's a way for us to
[Music]
make it clear
because
this language doesn't it seems to me a
little ambiguous and a little subject to
interpretation that i'm not comfortable
with
fetal anomaly incompatible with life if
we could if we could figure out how to
add it to a definition section or
somethings to say what's in and what's
out what's permissible and what wouldn't
be as by way of example but not by an
exhaustive list
that kind of thing would i i think would
be persuasive to me as an individual yes
may i respond i i
sort of take offense about saying people
who make their living on abortion these
people
the number of terminations secondary to
fatal fetal anomaly
is probably
could be counted on one hand per year
it's a very rare phenomena
and it is
not the major practice of these
individuals they're high-risk
obstetricians who usually
are managing to get these very difficult
situations through to term
with a surviving infant that's the goal
just like we try to save a kid who gets
run over
by a car and is basically brain dead we
do everything we can to save them but if
that kid is completely brain dead
and the parents say yes i agree with
termination of
life support systems they're making a
decision for another person who is
somewhat helpless at that point in time
it is not a sign of failure it is not a
sign that we were making our living by
letting this kid die it's a sign that
sometimes we cannot
work miracles
we do the best we can
this is a very small amount of a
practice would be a termination of
pregnancy for a fatal fetal anomaly the
great majority they're going to bring to
term successfully
or with maybe some problems the kid
might still have
but they'll do their best
this is why we should be trying to
practice medicine
in the legislature
so i think we're still
almost entirely agreed with one another
and i've made a request are you able to
help me
come up with some sort of a definition
to further clarify the
state of new hampshire's position
relative to what we consider appropriate
and inappropriate uses of this clause
i think that would be extremely
difficult because again
the truth
trying to make lists or can be difficult
things can change some things that were
not survivable 10 years ago are now
which is the practice of medicine
constantly evolves
and
i think again if we make a list we are
practicing medicine
we are saying these are things that
are
you know blah blah blah no it's a
judgment of the treating physician if
that treating physician
is wrong
they're going to face their board of
medicine
so ultimately representative wolf you're
going to have to determine what your
amendment looks like
yes i would i'm happy
not happy but i'm willing to go ahead
and proceed on this i'd like to just
back up
a minute
to let people know
why we're before this committee
got through the house
but it went to a second committee
because there's a very very small
financial
question in there
the that whole section that relates to
the financial question that brought us
before you and your committee
was because some of my friends
who are in the pro-life community
said we don't know how many abortions
there are they're our ex
and when i talk to the people at the
various hospitals they say they're a why
so we put in a reporting requirement
so that we could all know
as
representative connor just said is it 5
is it 25 or is it 2 and is it a weird
minimal thing
and that brought us
before you and i'm glad for this
committee to understand
that i'm not and was never throughout
this bill looking to hide
we wanted it all open and transparent
let's start with finding out how many
abortions there may have been after 24
weeks
do we have a situation where there
has to be action taken or is it two or
three
fetal abnormalities incompatible with
life that's what brought us before this
committee
so so i i understand that and i agree
with that um are you proposing that you
would have a uh in your amendment
something to do to change the reporting
requirement
i'm just curious i'm being i'm trying to
be clear
i'd look to your suggestion i'm happy
that we get as much information as
possible on this
do it does it
do we make it a law and
nothing coming out of the state i don't
know how you do that but i think we
should have as much information as
possible yeah
two you may know two terms ago we had a
bill uh in the house to
consider
accumulating abortion statistics and i
was defeated
so we would have had the data had we
passed that bill
there are
some statistics that are kept and i've
seen them i've lost that thing but uh
there are statistics out there okay
so so can i move on to the health issue
sure
um
so currently the uh one of the
exceptions exists
for
um the life of the mother and then i
think there are like four
sub sub categories of things that would
uh indicate whether or not a life is at
risk to include
problems with physical health
so um when if we were to simply add the
word
health or life
what the concerns are there that i'd
want to
mitigate
uh would be um
common things that are true with any
parent
parents get stressed when they have kids
at home stress can cause challenges to a
person's health
so
so when you add the if you if you wanted
us to add the word health and as an
exception to the 24 weeks
would you help me understand
how severe
a woman's health would have to be at
risk
for this
exemption to be leveraged would
the stress of raising a child be
enough or
and if that isn't enough then how would
i can't say
that i came up with this on my own
one of our republican representatives
told me about a case called doe
versus bolton
1973 u.s supreme court
its definition
of the health it's a georgia case
includes quote
all factors physical emotional
psychological familial and women's age
relevant to the well-being of the
patient
it's a supreme court case
i know that that may sound wide open to
you but that is what the law has been
for the last
61 years
51 years
okay so you you said you'd be open to uh
an amendment to where you would
eliminate rape and incest as as
exemptions for the 24 weeks
just curious what your thinking is there
i had a lot of discussions with a lot of
people about that and one of the
overriding concerns has been
an
individual a mother
should know
by 24 weeks
whether
they want to carry that baby
to term
i've had other instances where they've
been a father that has kept her daughter
his daughter
confined
and that's why i put it in there
or a rapist
and a woman is struggling and struggling
with the decision as to whether she
wants to have that child
so it was a difficult thing to say okay
we'll eliminate that
again i'd love to know the statistics
how many
cases of abortion occur after 24 weeks
from rape or incest
i don't think they're very many
do you think it's reasonable to think
that
um
a woman when when she becomes pregnant
that moment she becomes pregnant she
knows whether it's incest or sexual
assault and then has 24 weeks
to obtain an abortion for any reason
do you do you think
that's enough time to respond to
the conditions where the pregnancy
occurred in sexual assault or rape
i would certainly hope so i would
certainly hope
that we in the state of new hampshire
would give that woman the counseling
that's needed to help her reach a
decision that she's comfortable with
okay so so let's let's go on to they
like coming
absolutely thank you for stopping me go
in this in cases of incest particularly
especially if it's a younger adolescent
female
who is often under the control
of a
older male
family member
they may not be allowed
to access medical care
until perhaps the neighbor says you look
pregnant what the heck's going on
likewise
they're often quite traumatized and have
a great difficulty even trying to figure
out to deal with this
but the one that i think is most
striking and
most many people around here know i was
not an obstetrician i was a spine
surgeon
but i actually made a diagnosis of a
post-24 week pregnancy and a woman who
did not know she was pregnant i had a
young woman who came in
in the summer slender
uh she had back pain as many women who
were pregnant were but she did not know
she was pregnant
she looked slightly pregnant i actually
had a medical resident telling me that
day or shadowing me
as we finished the history and we left
out to the hall so she could change her
clothes i said to marcie who is with me
i said does she look pregnant she said
sorta
we went back in on exam i examined her
belly i could feel her uterus i hadn't
done an obstetrical exam for decades but
i could remember how to do it
and i confronted her and asked her is
there any chance she could be pregnant
so well you know i really haven't had a
period for a while but i just thought it
was you know just how way it was
and we did center for pregnancy testing
it turns out she was post 24 weeks and
she had no clue that she was pregnant
so a victim in other she if she were not
raped that would
her incest that wouldn't qualify but if
she had been a victim of rape or incest
she wouldn't have even
known
and she obviously knew she was exposed
uh but she did not think she was
pregnant so the point is
once again
we're sitting here trying to parse this
out and put ourselves in the sh in the
shoes
well we're not putting ourselves in the
shoes of a woman who has been raped or a
victim of incest
or did not have enough education to even
be able to figure out that she's
pregnant
and i do understand the previous comment
you made about deals but i still object
to the fact that we are trying to parse
out details of policy particularly
medical issues
in a non-policy committee this is why we
have a policy committee which i serve on
where we have a couple of docs nurses a
whole number of other providers
including mental health providers who
deal with these kinds of problems
and we worked on this
and i
really quite troubled that we're trying
to revamp this here in this committee
so representative knurk i'm i'm fully
willing to
not entertain any policy changes and and
just go to a vote is that is that what
your preference is that we that we not
consider any policy changes and we just
go to a vote
i know that our side will lose but i'm
certainly comfortable with that i think
it's a more honest way for us to be
doing business all right we're honest
people
so so
uh i'd like to take a straw vote at this
point
and i'm going to ask two questions the
first question is
are you in favor of
otp on hb
1609 we'll have a show of hands if
you're in favor of passing the bill as
is
and then we'll have a second vote
on if you're in favor of itl
h.b 1609 as is is is the question clear
okay so if you are in favor of
passing hb 1609 as is
please raise your hand
okay so we have three um if you were in
favor of itl hb 1609
okay so with a vote of four to three
we'll send this to the full finance
we're um i guess that's the committee's
decision
that that's our decision so we're done
okay
next up is
hb
relative to notice that a health care
provider is no longer accepting new
patients and relative to mental health
parity
would you start us off mr ripple by
giving us an update on the status of the
yes and i think this
i think i sent out a revised fiscal note
over the weekend for this one did i not
if i can hand out a hard copy to anybody
who needs one
why don't you uh just also also i'm
trying to get it into the record because
we we're on the youtube channel too so
if you could just let people know the
status sure yep so basically um we sent
this out to the insurance department who
states that the uh bill has amended is
will have no fiscal impact
uh and hhs states that the bill is
unlikely to have a fiscal impact unless
they're ordered to increase medicaid
managed care benefits to be in
compliance with the parity provision and
i did invite someone from the insurance
department to be here to speak about the
parity provision and that law generally
but the bottom line is there is no
fiscal impact
uh well as written there's unlikely to
be a fiscal impact it's not a straight
no fiscal impact like some of the other
bills that you've had today
all right so we'll ask the insurance
please state your name and title good
afternoon tyler brennan i am the life
and health director with the new
last name is spelled b-r-a
and
e-n
thank you
health insurance new hampshire health
insurance life and health director with
okay
so
i think
i just want to under you're the
insurance department right yes okay the
fiscal note reads the insurance
department states that this provision is
expected to have no fiscal impact
that is correct
okay so it's the next sentence
the department of health and human
services states the bill is unlikely to
have a fiscal impact so so what i think
we probably need to do because your
testimony is really clear from what we
need to know uh is to ask the department
of health and human services to come
forward to talk about their
part of the fiscal note okay do you i
don't want to stop you though if you
have something you want to say please do
thanks i would just say it does change
the commercial insurance statutes the
managed care organizations that
administer medicaid benefits are
operated basically under a contract
between dhhs and the mco the insurance
department does license and look at
solvency of the mcos but otherwise your
insurance laws would not apply to your
mcos so by changing just an insurance
commercial insurance statute that is the
limit of the impact of the bill
so so that impact you're referring to
the impact of on state dollars
but if but for an mco are you implying
that the mco would have added costs
and and when they have added costs that
they would be
possibly or probably passed on and
greater premiums so the only way that
would be the case is if something in the
contract between dhhs and the mco
says that it must have that kind of
impact because this legislative change
only impacts the commercial insurance
statutes that's where the impact is
directly limited right
all right thank you sure
and again just uh your name and your
good afternoon
for the record my name is robert berry
i'm the general counsel to d uh to
division of medicaid
i'm jenny o higgins i'm a legislative
liaison for the division for behavioral
health
can you both spell your last names
robert
barry b as in boy he is an elephant
r-r-y
like the fruit okay
danielle and it's o higgins o apostrophe
h-i-g-g-i-n-s
thank you
uh so we agree with the insurance
analysis of the bill
we're going to be submitting a corrected
fiscal note
essentially the bill is introduced had
some provisions that did have an impact
or potentially impacted hhs it seems
that those
that analysis got moved over into the
amendment and the bill is amended
so we'll be correcting that for the
record
uh all right i'm i'm sorry i lost my
train of thought for a second i i'm a
simple one or a zero guy a former
software engineer
will will there be
a fiscal impact no
no no
because in the write-up
as i currently see it
it's unlikely and are you
striking the word unlikely and you're
saying no correct
we it's a it's a holdover from the bill
as introduced which did have potentially
a fiscal impact when we submitted the
fiscal note that provision just got
carried over and wasn't properly removed
so that's that's what happens we'll be
correcting the fiscal note to reflect
that okay so mr ripple just to touch
base with you
what i hear is that the fiscal note will
be rather simple and just say there is
no fiscal impact is is is that your
understanding or am i i'm confused
that's what it sounds like
all right
okay
outstanding thank you so much
um
so
as we've discussed before if there's no
fiscal impact it's outside of our
jurisdiction and one way or the other
were to
basically
send it back and let the policy vote
stand
now i i had a sidebar with
representative walner we each spoke with
the clerk today
what the clerk said to me
is consistent with what he said to
representative wallner
but representative walner is better at
asking the follow-up question than i am
i think
uh i i
was informed that
if there is no fiscal impact in the
fiscal note after an amendment
that we should basically let the clerk
know and he could read a statement on
the house floor
that would uh obviate the need for
another vote
what representative wallner heard that
was supplemental to what i had been told
is that
if
the item has been scheduled
we are obligated to come up with some
kind of recommendation
and i have a fear that because we
put the actual bill numbers on on the
calendar that means we're going to have
to have a floor vote
eventually so is that your
interpretation representative walner
yes i think that's correct
um so
so for these if
i'm gonna verify what you verified but
assuming you're right
um
then in that scenario what i see us
doing is
otp'ing these
and explaining that there's no longer a
fiscal impact
is did anyone on the committee have a
problem with that want to see it
different
representative
okay
all right
so
i think we can wrap up hb 1622
um unless anyone in the audience want to
speak to this because i think
we're going to pass it
all right thank you 1622 uh is closed
point of voter then sir do we take a
vote on these ones that we
need to do the otp or is that just
happen over in the overall finance
that that's an excellent question i
should have
addressed that in advance but what i
want to do is i want to re-verify what
representative wallner is verified so
that monday we do the right thing so
it should be a short and sweet thing on
monday to to just wrap it up and know
sure
but we're going to have to do it monday
anyways because i want to know that
we're doing the right thing whether
we're just passing it back to the
committee with no recommendation because
it has no fiscal note or we're going to
do an otp so i'm
i i
i
i'm not ready to do a show answer
okay
so
that leaves us with three more bills to
go today hb 16 42
15 26 15 31.
um i i scheduled them at three
because i expected hb 1609 to
to run much longer than it did
so unfortunately we can't start those
three bills until 3 p.m
uh so i have to put us into recess until
then um
so we are in
you
uh representative kenner can we take our
uh okay so it being uh 302 uh i'm going
to call the um
today's hearing uh back out of recess
uh representative rogers has had to
leave uh leave us today so
i i promised her that given her
the vital need for her to leave that
that we would not conduct any straw
votes
which is a little problematic because um
i think we're ready to to decide on
1662.
uh now that representative weiler is in
we deferred for him to get here
so i'll look for guidance
from you representative walner and you
representative knurk
or do you do you think you two
would be in favor of 1662
otp
with the new fiscal note and there's an
amendment that
that mr ripple is going to bring to us
that clarifies one p a per it system and
that we're hiring a wage grade 30
instead of 32.
the fiscal note will be updated to
i don't i don't want to put you under
pressure we can come back i but if you
if you two are in favor of it then i
then i'd be comfortable
having us hold our vote without
yeah
just so the key was to say again for
each program and to change the grade and
that's all you're going to be changing
so far yes sir uh it's not quite a
program it's per itc
you would call it a project the program
would be the amalgamation of all the
projects got it sorry i i don't know
that terminology as well thank you
i think it makes sense i i because you
know we passed it out 18 to 3 in
committee and those changes you're
making are very minor the pay grade is
just a reality that's not something we
worried about and uh
the other part is just a clarification
as you point out i think it makes
perfect sense so i would certainly be
comfortable with moving ahead with that
uh amendment and uh moving on
all right um mr clerk i need some advice
i just uh stuck my head in and watched
division two and they took a a roll call
vote in their working group
and recorded roll call
and i i was under the impression that we
only needed to do
a raising of hands in order to record a
vote in a working group
so um i i could use some advice if we're
gonna vote on 1662 should we do a roll
call or a raising of hands
we should probably
we should probably do a roll call vote
on every one of these that we want to
send forward to the full committee
that's the purpose of having the the uh
division is so we come and as you note
when we sit down and have a
piece of paper before us telling how the
the different divisions always has a
vote
three to two or whatever
okay so i will do a roll call i will
entertain a motion
to accept
hb 1662 with the coming
amendment that mr ripple is preparing
the amendment will be limited to
changing the labor grade
and and the financial analysis from a
wage grade 32 to 30. but another note we
usually don't vote without the amendment
before us
okay so should we wait till monday
anyways yeah yeah
all right so
okay
so earlier we voted on 1609 with the
show of hands and it was a 4-3
let me do that one
well
representative rogers isn't here so we
wouldn't record or vote if we did it on
a roll call
so i i think we're going to have to um
wait remember how everybody voted
well i i do too i i
let me ask representative walner
representative uh kanerk if you have an
objection to us recording
a 4-3 vote on 1609 based on our how we
know everyone voted
i i would really let's just wait until
representative rogers is here on monday
we can go through these pretty fast on
monday don't you think i i agree i'm
fine with that so i just know she'd
okay
all right so with that i
oh and over our recess i validated that
representative walner is asks better
questions than i do because she got the
she got the proper response uh we if
once it gets calendared we have to vote
on it so um
so we will have to vote on all of those
on monday instead of just passing it
asking for them to waive votes
now i think i'm ready for to open
1642 relative to lead testing and
children
is there anyone from the department that
and then just
give us your name and your
it's on now
hi my name is beverly drewen and i work
for the division of public health for
the healthy homes and lead poisoning
prevention program
d-r-o-u-i-n
exactly
i think i've seen it before
good afternoon michelle roberge i'm the
bureau chief for public health
protection within the division of public
health services
michelle drewer michelle robersch r-o-b
all right what would you like us to know
at this point i think we want you to
know that the fiscal impact is negative
for the department of health and human
services
um
you don't literally mean negative i
think you technically you mean neutral
you are correct i do not mean negative
all right
yeah the amendment um
takes away any of the physical impact uh
that that we originally filed with the
fiscal
note worksheet so the new
fiscal impact is is neutral yes
i i want you to bring forward negative
fiscal impacts in the future please uh
but uh all right so um
there's probably no one here
representing the local school districts
so if that's the case is there anyone
here representing the local school
districts
not seeing any
would you speak to the other part of the
note that sounds like there's an
indeterminable cost
that would be
from our understanding is that the
concern was expressed
regarding
the need for schools and child care
facilities to
make sure that the lead testing was
completed so that they would and they're
currently already doing it for
other reasons so it's just an additional
check if you will for when the child
either enters the school system or a
child care facility and that's our
understanding of
the concerns that were expressed from
either child care facilities or schools
so i've recently had a lot of
conversations with the principal at the
auburn village school
and i i just want to make sure i
understand the situation because she's
going to ask me
okay
there's an indeterminable cost but we
know that there's a cost and it's
non-zero it's there's there's actually
some cost that the school systems are
going to have to pay
in order to support this change in
funding is that true or false and then
um
do you want me to ask mr ripple or or if
you're not i sense you're not
comfortable answering it yeah i'm i'm
not comfortable answering that because
i'm you know i'm not sure what the cost
would be for the school systems
okay you're in a safe zone you don't
have to answer so representative kenner
uh yes the this
the uh this is a bill i kind of adopted
in our committee and i this is the
amendment for it was mine to get rid of
all the fiscal impact it's important to
realize there already is a form
that exists it's called the new
hampshire early childhood health
assessment record
it is for use from birth through grade
three
it is the form that is already used when
kids come into child care for
child care systems for example and it is
where one documents all the various
immunizations and there already exists
the slot for the provider to check
uh for the lead levels
so it's already there for them to fill
out um on the form
so there really is no need for a new
form
all it is is a matter that they will
look and see that somebody entered a
lead test
when the time that they're checking the
form
um so i don't i do not expect that there
ought to be any kind of a big new cost
because this form already exists and
it's when the kids first enter which is
generally going to be kindergarten
so may i ask you a follow-up yes sir um
so
so the the form is already done and
complete and available to the schools if
i'm hearing you right and this is just
an issue
of them validating that they complete
the form properly it's best to
understand first of all it's important
to understand this was sent to me by the
people who do child care licensing that
this is the form that they're already
using but since it is labeled for use
from birth through grade three i do not
know for sure if all the schools do the
same thing but it's important to
understand that they already have the
health forms that are going to be filled
out by the providers anyway and it's i i
i you know it's it's since the providers
are used to it because it's a
requirement just to clarify the
requirement for this test we came to
sb247 in 2018 and it's a requirement by
age one and again by age two to have a
lead test parents can opt out if they
wish not to have their child tested and
that is not changed by this bill
the the point of this bill was simply
another point of contact to remind
parents of the importance of having
their child lead tested because if we
identify them early we can treat them
before you end up with lifelong learning
disabilities and other problems
so that's the whole point of this and so
the providers already are doing it it's
already in all of their ehrs which are
electric electronic health records which
is how most the provider the provider
records are actually kept and so there
really isn't a big large reporting
burden because they already have to
report things like the immunizations and
other factors when the kids enter
so is there a retro
retro active component to this or
are they sort of grandfathered in the
reporting that they've done or are they
going to be subject to going back and
correcting the records they have on hand
i do not it see it certainly was not
designed to be retroactive at all it was
a requirement for entry
um and so
uh
i i don't anticipate that there's any
retroactive work to be done first of all
once it kids it gets too old it's
not as much of an issue they're trying
to catch them when they're very young
because that's when you can make a big
difference in their life right i
remember that testimony yes i remember
we were together on that committee uh
representative walner did you have an
issue i just want could i ask a question
of the okay
so i
i just wanted to know
sort of what do you see as the
responsibility of the child care
provider if a family does not have this
done
after the six months
do you see child care providers having
to ask families to leave their facility
their programs
no that's not our understanding
generally they work with their
child care agencies to correct any
any issues that
that may arise so they
we're not from the child care licensing
group so
representative conner oh i'm sorry
i think kanark is going to respond to
your issue okay yes basically i i
followed i i did the follow up on that
because that question had been raised
and i spoke to the child care licensing
people melissa clements
and um
because the point of this is not to be
punitive
again the point is to be a reminder hey
your kid needs to be lead tested and
that is why there is also in here that
you know it when a parent suddenly gets
a very valuable child care slot we
didn't want them to lose that slot that
allows them to get to work because they
didn't have their kid lead tested so
there's a grace period to remediate it
and the question came up well what
happens if they don't and the answer is
nobody's going to throw the kid out the
way that they do this it's the same as
if a kid has not gotten their
immunizations documented
it comes up at licensing because this is
actually in the
licensing issues so at license review if
the agency determines that they have you
know
they're never checking it they'll say
you need to be checking this
if they find that there's one or two
kids they'll say there's a problem these
couple of kids have not gotten it and
their response will be the same as it is
with immunization they're going to try
to work with that kid they're going to
ask the child care agency to try to
remediate it but they're not going to
yank their license so they're not going
to throw kids out and that that was the
there was a conversation i had with
melissa clements the director of trial
care licensing
bureau chief i think it's called uh just
on friday i think it was so
we're we're okay there this is not a the
idea is not to throw people out the idea
is to remind her
representative waller you had another
point
no i just know that i've spent 50 years
in child care so i've been through this
you know i just want to be sure that
families are safeguarded from
losing
their place and particularly now because
getting into child care now
is like winning the lottery because
there are very few places available so
i don't want another
another stumbling block put in front of
families who need to to work so so
representative
you're i think you have a valid concern
do you do you see
[Music]
an advantage to making that clear in
no i would have to see what how we would
clear how we would make that clear i
guess i would want the department to
comment on how it could be
very clear
remember this is the finance department
the finance
committee but i do see that this could
have financial
it could end up having a financial
problem for a family
if they lost
their childcare position so
just
want to be sure that
it's not going to cause a problem for
families i i think addressing your issue
if we wanted to do would be pretty
simple it'd just be one more sentence
after the two bold areas
you know that says something the effect
that uh
no parent or child
would be held to
punitive
um
action
based on
whether or not they've
provided the test information
something like that mr ripple writes
better than i do i mumble and stumble
and then he he comes up with it
so
i
yes i think we would be fine with that
do you would you like to see that i i
would like to see something that that
clarifies that this won't be used as
a way for children to have to leave
we would be happy to review any language
and get back to you on any impact that
it may have um i can speak to
you know currently the department you
know this would be treated no
differently than what's currently the
department is currently doing with child
care licensing requirements now so any
of the requirements that are currently
in place um
this would be treated no differently
than what they're currently doing now
for immunizations and other and other
things so there is no intention
from the department's perspective
to to treat it any differently or be
punitive if
if it goes beyond the six months period
or anything
representative nerd uh yes indeed
because it is in the licensing it's in
170 e 19 and that is the licensing
statute and that's precisely what
melissa clement said that it would be
treated precisely the same as all the
other licensing record-keeping
requirements it is actually just one
part of the record keeping
so yeah there's nothing here about
a health issue of throwing a kid out
because there isn't
it's purely a matter of the licensing
and so that's not a
expulsion
but i i would have no objection i didn't
think about having that in when i
drafted this amendment but i would see
no problem with it because that's the
intent and that's how it's already
treated so we wouldn't really be
changing anything all right
thank you mr chair i i apologize but i'm
really confused here
it seems like
the law already exists that the children
need to be
tested
and that the local school authorities
need to
report that
i mean i'll read the sentence the
results of the child's physical
examinations shall be presented to the
local school officials on a form
provided by the local school authorities
so i'm curious as to why we need a new
form
and i'm concerned about representative
wallner's point as well they shall be
graded i think that means granted six
months to remedy the deficiency so the
presumption is there that something's
going to happen and they don't remedy
the deficiency
and then in the next line it basically
they're allow the parents can basically
opt out yes
so
what is the end why are we doing all why
are we putting the school officials
through all this if they're already
basically doing everything including the
testing but but they're not that's the
point the what this the the bold is the
new language the other language is
what's in statute that has to do with
this the standard physical examination
and other things such as immunization
that currently exists
the reason for this is that the lead
testing requirement went into effect
again it was a result of legislation in
2018 but the compliance rate has been
relatively low now part of that is
because we've also had a little problem
with the thing called code for the last
couple of years that is certainly
interfered with
people getting to their pediatrician and
getting blood tests done and so on and
so forth but the compliance has been
relatively poor comparison to what it
should be the initial bill had all kinds
of reporting requirements from the
schools as to how many people had been
tested from the providers all those are
the things that generated the fiscal
note and it's for that reason that the
amendment got rid of all of that stuff
but the point is this is at a point of
contact where a child enters into a
system of either child care or school as
a reminder that you know it's really
important your kid get tested for lead
and that was the reason this was put in
because the the blood testing
is
not
required
explicitly
for the school thing i mean they want to
have the form but we didn't ever say
that for the child care they have to
have the lead testing done even though
it should be this is just a way to try
to improve compliance with the testing
follow-up yeah
i thought i heard you state that the
form the the current form
already contains the blood level testing
checkbox or whatever it is on it
it yes sir it does it but they're not
required to have necessarily uh filled
that in in the past the goal was to make
sure that that is actually done in other
words there was no
there was no sort of checking to be
served it actually had gotten carried
out as far as lead testing whereas we
already have the immunization and
statute that's pretty clear so
i think that was the whole goal of this
if if i understand
but perhaps mrone could discuss that
better
so you're accurate the form already
exists with the blood lead the space on
the form for the blood lead to be
checked off that has been
been performed
but the schools aren't um
they're looking at the immunizations and
not so much looking at the lead form the
lead check box so what what this would
do is it would
have the schools look at the entirety of
the form to make sure that child had a
blood lead
blood level test
with the goal of increasing testing
rates and if parents had a child going
into kindergarten or first grade that
had a blood test they would know that
their younger children also need a blood
test
yeah so it's to increase awareness and
to improve testing rates
follow-up go ahead
so how are you going to inform
the schools of this this becomes law how
are you going to inform the schools that
i think that we would work with the
department of education
to do a press release news release and
some education to the school nurse we'd
work with the school nurse association
which we already collaborate and partner
with now
follow-up
so you'll probably see where i'm going
with this
why don't you just do that why do you
need
a bill why don't you just inform the
schools that you'd like them to actually
pay attention to that check box that
already exists and apparently pay
attention to the law regarding lead
testing that already exists
so the department is neutral on this
bill
and so we would
we would encourage any opportunities to
increase testing rates as possible
and
i'm sorry can you repeat your question
let me say it in my own way
i
it seems like
everything that you need from a
statutory perspective is in place and
from an administrative perspective the
form is already available
the requirement to do lead testing is
there
so
we have a training and compliance issue
we don't have a statutory issue it seems
to me
so
why couldn't this problem be solved
instead of with this
change to a statute
and instead be solved by just better
training
you know the department is does do uh
coordinated reach outreach to physicians
and to schools where we can this is just
another opportunity to increase
the awareness that this is an important
public health issue and to make sure
that parents at the local level they're
getting that another
communication with the schools around
the importance of lead testing so have
we have we tried in better training and
because i just hate going to the club of
all
additional laws
when everything's already in place and
we just need to do more training if have
we tried the better training approach
so we've had a full-time health educator
on staff since 2015 working with health
care providers our hud agencies our
school districts our school nurse
associations and our testing rates for
one-year rolls is in the 60 percent dial
right now
all right representative
yeah just to answer representatives
question
in terms of why is it different
we're actually trying to treat this so
it is the same if we look at
immunization yes we have a law that you
have to be immunized unless you have an
exemption to it but in 141 c 20 section
two
it says no child shall be admitted or
enrolled to a school or child care
agency unless they are immunized as
listed under paragraph one so the point
is in statute we say yes you got it be
immunized here we also then add and if
you're going to enter a school or child
care
we need to be immunized so here we have
a statute that says you have to be
tested for lead got it but there is no
correlating statute that says and to be
entered into a child care or school you
have to be tested for lead so indeed we
are trying to make the lead testing
just like the immunization so the point
is the difference is
that right now they do have it on the
health forum against because you know
from a provider's point of view you
don't want a gazillion forms you want
one form for the kid that kind of covers
everything it covers things like
allergies and
eating problems and all that kind of
stuff is on these kind of forms but the
issue is that
the providers the school sorry sorry the
school or the child care need to check
that they've got the immunizations this
is just asking them to also check that
they've got the lead so it makes it
exactly analogous to how we do treat
immunization so this does make it
consistent with our previous efforts in
immunization
it doesn't add something that is
different
so this sounds contradictory to me
because
we had a sidebar that representative
wallner started to say
we don't we don't want this to be
punitive we don't want to keep kids out
of these facilities for the lack of lead
testing but i think i just heard you say
that we can keep kids out of school and
child care facilities if they've not
been immunized
and now you're making a case that they
should be
now exactly analogous to one another so
if that's the case then that means there
is a punitive component of not doing the
lead testing could you could you
straighten me out on that
i think the point you make
is interesting and i hadn't thought
about that and i but i still don't view
it as really punitive because it's not
the goal still would be the licensing
people have said is they're going to
treat it like immunization which is they
don't throw a kid out of child care they
ask him to get it corrected and remember
just as an immunization and then testing
well i certainly
support
the
what's why we have the bill in front of
us i guess i just want to be sure
i guess i would just like to have a
sentence in there saying that um
you know a child cannot be removed from
child care if they don't have the lead
test
i understand the immunization because if
you have a child who's not immunized
and then that child
gets
whatever
thing they've been immunized against
or not against and then it spreads to
the other children
the lead testing's a little different it
doesn't spread to other children
so if we could just be sure that can't
be used just the lead testing can't be
used as a reason
to have a family not be able to have
their child in child care okay earlier
you said they should not be removed but
i think what we're also needing to just
put a pin in
is they neither should they be denied a
slot or entry or enrollment into a
program because of the lead testing
right right and actually uh sure may i
yeah and actually it none of the it
doesn't to deny that's why there's this
and again that was a typo that uh
representative picked up as graded as
granted actually yes it was a typo that
they have the six months but i agree i'm
very comfortable with the idea of
putting in that it is not a cause to
dismiss a child just because
the licensing
or deny yeah but just because the
licensing agency says they would not do
that i think having it in statute makes
it safer so i completely agree with
representative walner and i'm
comfortable with adding deny i think
i had representative
i have two questions
how prevalent is
this affliction of
children having led and how much does
the
so in our last uh bill in 2018 we made
it so that
insurance coverage for blood lead
testing was mandatory that no insurance
company could deny a child
it costs a health care provider
approximately 32 dollars which they're
reimbursed
from the insurance company
so that's your first question then you
wanted to know how many children in new
hampshire
what percentage what percentage of
children tested so we had i'm looking
here through my recent data
682 children last year who had elevated
blood lead levels over five micrograms
so the
the so that represents approximately one
half of one percent of all students dude
i'm sorry i don't have that at my
fingertips i can find that data for you
so you're asking me of all the children
who enter into kindergarten what percent
would have an elevated blood lead i can
find that out for you
okay if it's phrased that way as opposed
to all kids then the numbers sounds like
it's probably more
around
uh
10 or 12 percent so what i can tell you
is 40 percent of the children who are in
k-12 right now here in new hampshire 40
of those children have had an elevated
blood lead test at some point in their
lives
okay and you said that commercial to
representative wilder's question you you
said that
uh commercial insurance reimburses the
32 dollars okay but i think only 60
percent or 60 percent of new hampshire
kids or thereabouts is covered by
commercial insurance
so who's paying for the other 40 percent
so children who are insured by medicaid
anthem tufts blue cross blue shield all
the insurance carriers those insurance
carriers
have to
cover the cost we have the wic clinics
who are doing blood lead testing for
children who might not have a medical
home that should that blood testing is
provided free of charge to those
children
do you have a follow-up representative
weiler
representative kenner do you have
another question or comment uh comment i
was trying to find the information i
don't have it right now but basically
it's important to understand and we
both edwards and i spent a long time
listening to this when we had the lead
bill 247 back in 18.
new hampshire has the oldest housing
stock in the nation which and of course
the housing and the lead paint is the
primary source of lead poisoning but
also it does come about from
contamination in the soil as well
and it leads to incredible problems with
children if in terms of learning issues
and behavioral issues and so on and is a
incredibly important preventable
illness
the
point is that many many children can be
exposed and the problem is trying to
pick them up early when we can treat
them and chelate out the lead and also
then we may know that there's a younger
sibling who can then be protected by
remediation and part of sb247 was money
to help remediate the housing stock when
necessary it's going to cost i think the
estimate was somewhere close to a
billion with a b to remediate all the
high-risk housing costs in the state so
we're not we can't just scatter shot do
it um
so though it may be a small amount it's
extremely important as far as a
screening test and that's why it was
passed in 2018 and that's why
this drone is here
so so i'll tell you why i'm unconvinced
at this point i'm unconvinced at this
point because it sounds like everything
that's needed legislatively is already
in place and what we're missing is the
training component
that that we're looking for a reason to
go out and train them to do what they're
already should be doing
and i i i'm just reluctant to pass
additional laws
rational people will act in their
self-interests if they knew how
important this lead testing was uh and
and and that
the schools needed to look for that
bubble that's filled out on the form and
report it
uh i i i just i just don't see the value
of adding to the thickness of our rsas
may i respond the point is the schools
are not currently required to do that
again they are for immunizations the
fact that it exists on the form is
because the provider just say we don't
tell them that they need to check is
there does the kid have an allergy
that's on the form
what we're asking is what this bill asks
is that they would actually check it
because the schools and child cares are
not required to check it it's just the
the spot exists on the form but the
provider may not fill it out
or the child may not have been tested
and nobody knows that nobody picks up on
it because it currently is not
required that they look at it this the
whole point of this is to ask them just
to take a look at it and say yep lead
test was done
are there any other comments from or
questions from the panel or from anyone
in the audience
do you two ladies have anything more you
want to say you've heard a lot
i think that the only adding comment
that i would add here today is that
other states who have put these policies
in place in school it's the data's shown
that increases testing rates
testing your children early is the only
way for an intervention to reverse the
the damage of lead poisoning it's an
invisible
thing that happens it's not self-evident
to any parents so you don't know unless
you're tested but if you do have early
intervention
then
the damage can be reduced and that child
can be back on mainstream and
if there's not early intervention
there's downstream cost that people
don't often see and the downstream cost
are to medicaid to the insurance company
to the juvenile justice system to
special education so what we try to do
is we try to test these children early
and often so we can get them the
intervention that they need so that
they're not a lifelong burden on our
system here in new hampshire
and that's what lead testing is all
about would you believe i could agree
with a hundred percent of everything you
just said
and say that you were so powerful in the
way you say it
that a training program
would have people behave rationally and
go get the
the form isn't compelling behavior the
the presence of a form doesn't solve all
the downstream problems you said it's
it's the act of the parent to take the
kid to go get tested and this form isn't
going to do that
anymore
if we compel it because i think that's
what we're avoiding
this is intended to compel parental
behavior that the state expects of them
and we're skip we're going from uh we
instead of trying to work the voluntary
angle
and the rational behavior angle we're
going to a compelling the parent
and and that's
that that's that's what i'm not
convinced on and but i may misunderstand
this so go ahead representative kenner
well one of the problems we've run into
is that the very people who are at the
greatest risk for lead poisoning
live in our worst housing and are often
some of the most dysfunctional families
or families where their parents are
working you know three different jobs
and are
you you say
education you know will
encourage proper behavior
so let's say they don't behave
should the child be punished with a
lifelong learning disability because we
didn't do our job to reach out to try to
help that child
and i know that that sounds like
you know perhaps we're overstepping our
bounds but i don't think we are because
not every parent
is capable of
doing what needs to be done and the
point of this again was not compelling
but it's another point of contact to
remind that's why again i agree 100
percent there should be that language in
there that says kids don't lose their
slot then they can't be denied because
the hope of this was simply
another point of contact say you know
you really need to get this done and
again that's not in law currently to
make that statement so i think
it still could be beneficial
um because the
i i think if i remember right there the
department is working hard on outreach
already
to those most vulnerable kids because we
know that those are the ones at highest
risk and they're the ones where the
parents are least likely to actually
so i think you may be projecting
benefits of the pro of this law that uh
are are theoretical this this law is
just
looks like it's setting up to compel the
completion of a form
um
like i said i'm just not convinced that
a good training program wouldn't be
adequate that that's all
one point if i could make is the policy
committee passed this 20 to one because
we thought it was a good thing although
i think the policy committee would
perfectly have been happy with what
representative walner has said
and
the policy committee also amended out
all the language that would induce the
cost to the department
and the cost to the schools should be
rather negligible since they already
have a form they're gathering and they
just have to look at one other spot and
see that something was checked and
remind the parents if it wasn't
um
so i'm not quite sure why we
why you have an aversion to this bill
and when we thought as a policy
committee it was a good bill i know i'm
here as a sub today but i'm still no
you're doing great
you you're welcome here anytime
so so
the reason i'm i'm picking at this is
because i've had a lot of conversations
with the
my local principal
and how upset she is at the legislature
passing unfunded mandates and if we're
trying to get the schools
if we're trying if ultimately if we're
trying to get the parents
to do the lead testing like they should
and uh
in fact we're trying to give them
incentives or to compel them to behave
the way we want them to
we're basically going to be asking the
schools and the day care centers to be
agents of the state to help us enforce
that so we are putting a mandate
on the school systems that
for them to do additional work
to me that's an unfunded mandate and
because that's a financial issue i i see
the whole bill is as being open to
this so
so that's that's why i'm pushing on it
and i think we just have a difference of
opinion representative
uh representative erf
uh thank you mr chair first i just want
to reiterate so i understand that the
lead requirement for lead testing is
already in statute sure okay
so that's not what we're trying to
increase
it's very likely based on what you've
all said today
that our
testing is much higher than 40
because all you're saying is this box
hasn't been checked
it's very possible that the testing has
gone on but the
schools aren't checking it and that's
why i keep asking the question about
it's tracked in a different way
ms drone should answer that question
the division of public health healthy
homes and lead poisoning prevention
program
is this responsible for blood lead
surveillance for the entire state ages
zero through death so all blood lead
tests for all children and adults come
into our come into the division of
public health where our epidemiologists
and statisticians calculate the blood
lead testing rates so the 2020
blood lead data was just released and
this is pre pandemic so this is when
things were
doing much better we tested 63 percent
of all the one-year-olds in the state
and 53 percent of all the two-year-olds
in the state so we the vision public
health
does have our hand on our pulse our hand
on the pulse of the children who are
tested it's it's reported directly from
the healthcare providers in the
commercial labs the lab cores the quests
so the bottom line is that the statute
requiring the lead testing is that's
the statute is in place to require all
one and two-year-olds to be tested in
the state it's just a matter of
making sure that that's happening
throughout the state at the provider
offices
but she just told us that you have the
data that tells you that you know
only six to three percent of some age
group was tested that says to me 37
percent
weren't tested
which means the statute requiring the
testing is not working is that not
accurate
i i think um what i i would just add to
that is we have a lot of families here
in the state of new hampshire who who do
not have a medical home they do not have
a doctor
so these families might get their blood
testing at the wic clinic when they're
getting their their food products or
they might not get testing at all they
i think you're doing very good the
sounds adversarial we're really just
trying to dig in and understand okay so
socrates even did this sort of thing so
uh
uh representative kenner but
representative was sort of right there
in a sense it isn't working the way we
want it to we'd like to have you know
closer to 100
that's what the goal of this bill was is
to another point of contact where people
you know we're where we can actually
have a contact with a parent uh to
remind them that it's important that the
goal of this was simply to improve that
compliance because it is not working as
well as we would like it again the
original part of the bill had reporting
by individual providers with all kinds
of data that was what actually induced
the or caused the fiscal impact to the
state and that's what we amended out
because there was no appropriation we
knew that there was no way that that was
going to be able to pass
so all of that which
would have been a perhaps a cleaner way
to try to track it and find out which
providers are doing the testing and not
it was just
not not reasonable to consider without
an appropriation and we knew that was
not forthcoming so we amended that out
all right
have all the
committee members ask their questions
department have you told us everything
all right
so um
we will not be voting on 1642 today uh
representative representative ripple
uh dr ripple i should say uh
no miss mr ripple uh would you work on
an amendment to we'll call it the walnut
amendment to stick
stick the um claws in there that this is
not to be used punitively to deny
enrollment or continuation of
their position in the school or the day
care center
sure and that was my only question is
whether you wanted it to apply only to
section two child day care centers or to
public schools in section one as well
i i would i would do both um now uh on
the day care center side of it we're
kind of getting up into the private
businesses
but we're saying that this is a reason
not to deny
them
in enrollment which i think is is fair
um
because lead poisoning is not contagious
to the best of my non-medical knowledge
so and i agree with doing both sir thank
you
all right
okay so with that 1642
uh is recessed until monday to consider
i'm going to open this now on uh house
bill 1526 relative to income eligibility
for in and out medical assistance and
i'll invite both representative snow and
mr lipman up uh because i think we
already see we've got
two sides to this or at least two big
and then representative snow would if
you'd lead us off on what you'd like us
yeah
on the surface this bill seems
relatively simple
house bill 1639
which was passed in the last session of
the legislature asked the department of
health and human services to take a look
at
the minimum qualifying income for
medicaid in and out which they did
and that bill was submitted with some
recommendations about how to move ahead
and
there was
recommendations about how to be funded
through the
department
this this committee was concerned about
some of the implications of other
financial issues that were going on
and felt that it was necessary to
suspend
new funding for that program
for this
tr
by biennium
and this bill is simply a request that
if this situation is stabilized at all
we would like to request
that that suspension of the funding for
this program be lifted so it could be
funded beginning july 1st of this year
for the second year of the biennium and
thereafter i think it's a very important
bill
we have fallen somewhat behind
in bringing it up to date and
hopefully we can move ahead and make it
more effective both for clients
and for a lot of the providers in the
state and i think i'll leave it at that
because
there's any questions if you want
details i i have two questions for you
representatives now
one
when we caucused on this the republicans
um we should have brought the democrats
in to make us smarter but um we didn't
uh would you none of us could remember
how these payments got suspended in the
first place and our theory
was that the suspension of payments
was initiated by the other uh
chamber
do you do you know the politics of this
of who did this no i don't i just know
that we assumed that it was going to be
funded
and all we heard was that the finance
committee felt
uneasy about the availability of the
funds and decided to suspend they didn't
say whether it was the senate or the
house i never got any feedback on that
whatsoever
represent or mr lipman did you it looked
like you may have
know something for the record henry
littman medicaid director
my recollection is the policy was
approved and
as representative snow and all we're
talking about here is raising
or making it easier for people to
to qualify because the financial
standards haven't been updated for a
long long time and so that
it was the fact that to
change the standards
would cause us to spend more money i
think it was around 13 million for the
two
two years or 12 million for the two
years that i think at the time there was
uncertainty around the budget
remain
it remained
unfunded in this
latest biennium
and i apologize i didn't really
introduce myself i'm
i'm representative ken snow from
manchester i represent ward 12 in
manchester
just historically i have
uh 50 years of work in the community
mental health movement across the and 48
of those
took place right here in new hampshire
so i'm very familiar with some of the
issues that goes on in that area and
i think that this particular bill
is much more important in the work that
those community mental health agencies
are doing than people really understand
it's not a
in and out medicaid is not a concept a
lot of people really understand
but it can be extremely important for
some people that otherwise will have to
go without services or
be left outside of the system and i'd be
glad to explain more but i don't want to
take up a necessary time if you already
know what the bill is all about
representative weiler
it's not clear to me when we say the uh
program was suspended it was suspended
at the higher
income rate or we still had the program
we had a book we had a program but the
maximum allowable income or that
threshold that allows people to be
qualified or have to go through other
steps to get qualified
remain the same as it has for the last
30 years 30 years okay thank you and and
since we passed the budget inflation has
uh representative irf did you have
something
if
if the committee wouldn't mind i
wouldn't mind hearing his explanation of
the program because i'd like to
understand more about it but if nobody
else wants to hear that then i i want to
hear it this is uh this is i had never
even heard of in and out except for the
burgers in california
until 48 hours ago so i'd i'd appreciate
do you want me to explain it or want to
mr liverpool you always missed me why it
was called in and out not out and in
because
what happens here is people begin the
month out of medicaid and if they meet
certain standards they're then in but
it's called in and out so we'll have to
leave it with that
but what this means is that
some
low-income uninsured individuals
have an income that's slightly
somewhat above the standard to qualify
for them for regular medicaid
this is simply a program and it is
exists in most states across the country
it's a program that's
part of the center for medicaid and
medicare service medicare and medicaid
services
and they have certain guidelines and
recommendations about how it's to be
flexibility in terms of how the state
applies it but basically what it says is
that you set
this threshold and if they're slightly
above it
that individual is allowed to document
any legitimate medicaid eligible
medical expense as long as they document
that once
that spend down brings them down to that
threshold for the balance of the month
they're qualified to have their other
so i see you nodding mr
would you have anything to extend that i
think the
in terms of the the limits i think if
i'm remembering right now don landry's
policy person is in the back here she
can correct me if i'm wrong but for
example it allowed for your housing
expenses to be 590 dollars a month and
and we know if remember during testimony
that you know you can't rent typically
um
at that level anymore so the the problem
is people have
expenses that are are not considered
and um they don't
remain on medicaid unless they
incur medical expenses so i think what
the idea here is that
from the provider and the patient's
standpoint is to consistently know
that you're going to be
covered by medicaid without having to
go through a process of redocumenting
every month that you've had
you're poor enough if you will and
you've had expenses large enough to to
go on the program
representative
so just so understand that makes perfect
sense and thank you for that so
the
the the uh he spends some money gets
down to that income limit now that
medicaid picks it up when the next month
begins does he then still have to spend
down to that whatever that level is so
it's an ongoing process if you're right
across the
threshold yes yes
and i think we estimated around a
thousand individuals are
on this
threshold thank you very much for the
explanation i really appreciate it
so so these are people that are on
ongoing care programs yes yes and when
you say really only applies to people
low-income people who are uninsured who
have ongoing and pretty overwhelming
medical expenses that it would be
impossible to meet
with
whatever income they would have
available to them in any way that's
that's really what it is and speaking
from a community mental health standard
many of the people that we dealt with
over the years are people that
are certified as having a severe and
persistent mental illness which means
they need ongoing care over a longer
period of time both in terms of services
and maintaining of medications and other
things to keep them on an even keel and
so they can function comfortably in the
community and
this is very valuable to them because
some of them do have income that puts
them slightly above
that
minimum threshold that gets them in but
this allows them to continue i will have
to say
that
the minimum income that's used here in
new hampshire is among the lowest of
anywhere in the country frankly
the minimum income which is 30 years old
back in the early 90s when this was
established
the the minimum income was set at
dollars a month for a single individual
now that's a little less than 150
dollars a week to meet all your expenses
and i would challenge anyone in this
room to think they could meet all their
expenses on 150 a week there was a time
when you could easily do that but you
can no longer do that and that's what we
tried to do is to bring that standard up
and
thanks to mr lippman and the state they
did do a very good job of getting a much
better standard
that accomplishes two very important
things
one is it
it means that the spend down they're
going to have to
pay each month becomes less in order to
meet the standard because suddenly the
threshold is raised to a higher amount
so they only have to go to that level in
order to qualify
secondly at least the estimates by his
office of the people for example that we
serve
with severe and persistent mental
illness for example
one third or possibly more we don't know
exactly
their new their income with this new
threshold would be below that threshold
so they would be shifted immediately out
of the fee for service in and out
program
into one of the managed care programs
for regular medicaid which is much more
efficient and cost effective way to
administer it so that's a distinct
advantage of doing that
secondly i think that one of the
problems is of the people that we serve
especially with this lower income level
this spend down
they can't pay it it would be like
getting blood from a stone
the mental health centers
each year
generate bad debt in the amount of
somewhere between seven and seven and a
half million dollars
and that's pretty substantial to try to
work that in
other facilities hospital emergency
rooms run into the same situation when
people come in prior to having met
that
that threshold requirement
can't collect and the person just has no
ability to meet that standard so
the increase in the threshold is a very
important step and that's why we're
interested in in moving ahead with it
and seeing if it won't overall improve
the program and more importantly would
reduce the amount of bad debt
the community mental health centers and
probably the hospitals have to endure
you should know that this bad debt
is one half state money
in one half the federal match
so the
what happens with new hampshire even
though that seems very high
and it is high because it
you know
it's money that we did not get
but
um
i think he made my point i i
don't want to go
representative for follow-up
so you said the original amount was 591
per month what what what is it now under
the new 901
representative conner yeah just the
couple of things i passed out as we
began i mentioned to rep edwards that we
had these things handed out when we
heard the bill and so i passed them
around to you just to make it a little
easier for you i think the easiest one
to understand is if you look at the one
from nami new hampshire
champ paragraph two discusses how this
in and out works you know in written if
you kind of follow written issues better
than oral
and gives the number in the middle of
that
paragraph that 591 and in the third
paragraph down toward the bottom it
talks about the new number for a
household of one that the threshold in
keys to 901
the bottom line thing to impor to kind
of understand about this is
we're looking at really simply a cost of
living
adjustment if you will i looked up and
googled if you have a hundred dollars
back in 1992 what is that in 2002 2022
i'm sorry and it's 202 dollars in other
words twice as much
we have
this all this does is correct what the
inflation has done to people
since that time it was set at 591 it's
not realistic to consider the numbers in
1992 are the same as we're dealing with
now
it doesn't even bring them up to make it
as high a threshold as was designed in
because if one did that it would
actually be more on the order of about
so it brings it up
really closer to about
two-thirds the way up
to what inflation has done
so i look at this as just simply an
adjustment to make sure that it fits
well
with what's happened to the costs over
that 30 years i also had a question for
mr litman if i could ask that question
because of the fact you have to document
in and out on a monthly basis
we keep talking about what the increased
cost would be for you know putting
getting people onto medicaid but what
would be the decreased cost because of
the
no longer the need to document every
month whether people are in or out and
what time of the month and checking
every single bill they got how much do
there is a cost associated with that
representative canark i think that in
terms of if you then reversed and said
how many people could we cut as a result
of changing that i don't think it would
be because there are certain procedures
that have to go on i think the burden is
really
the cost of fuels absorbed by
the beneficiaries who have to
to
document things and then by the the
providers who end up
you know having to either work with
people or chase them and spend
collection costs so i think that's where
the costs with savings would be um occur
that's not counted in what i said was
bad debt but it is a significant amount
of effort on the part of
both the treatment staff and other
management staff within the center to
make sure that we stay right on top of
what
each person's legitimate expenses have
been so that we can implement the
representative weiler
the confusion is
the way the the bill is written it says
repeal
and it gives the numbers requiring the
department of health and human services
to amend the income eligibility standard
for the in and out medical assistance
policy is repealed
so
is that the 591 that's repealed and
and shouldn't we replace it with
something or is it just leave it up to
the
i don't know what that mean i
when i used repeal i was hoping we would
repeal the suspension and move ahead
with the
activating the programs what i think it
means but i don't know
maybe awkwardly
i didn't
physically write the bill we may know an
i think the answer is that the policy
was approved and voted into law that
that repealing this particular thing
would
put into law the policy that was
approved in 19 is my understanding i
don't know if if
you can confirm that kevin
yes i think that's right the policy was
in place it was suspended in the trailer
bill so by repealing that suspension it
would put the policy back into effect
do you know how it got into the trailer
bill
i think the suspension was first added
the department i believe had requested
that the senate either
fund the policy at the 12 or 13 million
or
suspend
uh rather than leave it in place with no
funding and the senate opted to suspend
it and that change was
approved in committee of conference
all right so uh
okay representative walner
um well so from what kevin just said
it seems like the house position
was to
have this program in place is that
correct
that was the house position there was no
funding associated with the program in
the house position though um
i'm not sure i don't recall if during
the house phase the department came
forward with language to suspend it or
not
so i don't want to speak to whether the
house made a conscious decision to
keep the program in place
or not
so it just strikes me that the
at least
the house side division three
we we fully funded this portion of the
governor's budget
and
and and so i don't remember us ever
having a discussion about
not funding
uh this line item because the line item
would have been part of
some other program and we were funding
programs at the governor's budget level
for the most part
uh you did generally fund programs at
the governor's budget level i would say
in this area
the governor did not fund this increase
to 133 and a third percent and i think
you would see that if you went back to
the agency budget request
they had a number associated with this
the governor did not include that number
um so the plot thickens it's the
governor who didn't want to fund this
[Laughter]
finally we got him
go ahead mr living you want to say
something
one further recollection i have is that
i think that was passed
with a june 30th date with the
anticipation that in the
there'd be funding in it and then if you
recall we kind of with what was going on
with
state finances at one point thinking we
were going to be at a 500 million dollar
deficit that that it didn't
didn't get funded and
and
that's really i think what ended up
happening is that the policy was agreed
to and then
expected it would get funded in the next
session and it didn't
for for reasons that
you know in
a certain time of year you would know
and later on you would have a different
perspective so let the record reflect
that mr lipman defended the governor uh
said he was making a decision in a
period of pandemic confusion so okay so
i got a totally different question for
you i want to get to this other question
of the
6073 individuals that are in the in and
out program
how many of them fall into this category
that i think representative snow
described as severely mentally ill or
what it was something like that about
well i can tell you the last time we
counted it exactly it was just under
2500 about 24
64. so
it continues it's stabilized that around
2500 people are in the in and out
program who have that
oh okay so so we're talking of the
nearly 60 manchester
now across the whole state
i have those figures
right here
across the whole state
no i'm sorry you're correct it's 2500
for all 10 mental health centers our
particular one
with 365 but
that's the number of people that benefit
from this there are other people
i'm just i'm sorry can we just stick to
my regular medicaid i'm just i'm just
asking questions and
i'm just trying to ask precise questions
okay so
so i think i think the answer
and
let's correct the record if it's not
right but it's 2500 of the approximately
are
those with civil severe mental illness
a diagnosis and keep in mind some of
that 2500 also have co-occurring medical
problems
that also add to the dilemma they have i
mean older people can have diabetes
so so where i'm going with this is mr
lipman
is there a way
to do i'm concerned about maintaining
the
vibrancy of our community health
center infrastructure
is there a way to carve this out so that
we
you know much like we did with the
adult dental benefit is there a way to
carve this out so that we can authorize
some money for
uh the the the severely mentally ill
the answer unfortunately i think is no
with a butt um
and
i asked
anticipating that might be your question
um i asked don landry to research a
little bit new hampshire um in
establishing disability and the like
became what they call a 209 b state
meaning that we could set our own
criteria versus having to go on federal
criteria and that goes
way back to i don't know
1972 sorry
and
when you have that status you have
certain flexibilities of setting your
own state specific criteria but there's
a condition with that with this
particular program
and i don't think you'll find trouble
based on the venture discussion with who
you do have to cover you have to cover
the blind
the disabled um
who else am i missing nursing home
aged people who are in and
maybe
not in a nursing home but just aged old
and poor if you will
those are the ones you do have to cover
so you could limit it to
to a certain group of what might call
fragile
individuals in the community
okay so for cover if uh 2500 are
severely mentally ill that leaves about
3 600 others development are those 3 600
others are they big
beneficiaries if we were to approve this
in and out modification
so we're we anticipated about another
thousand individuals would come on to
the program who are now going out
on a monthly basis
we it's hard to predict because you
don't know how
people's incomes are are changing
but i would
say that um the current composition
probably is is as good a
perspective of the number of people who
would benefit or not so if
40 percent of mental health i wouldn't
couldn't come up with a better number
for you unfortunately without having the
so i'm gonna
assume what you just told me to my
question is that they are also equally
uh demanding
uh customers for or beneficiaries of the
in and out program that the the
consumption rate between mentally ill
and the others is it's the same
it's the same consumption rate
um if if we're talking about their
monthly medical expenses
that
there is variability i think that i was
talking about their
income levels to be able to qualify for
the program um
i could i don't have it off the top of
my head but there
um
we do have specific categories of what
their managed care costs were and that's
um i'm sure we took in developing that
estimate that we took
the current blend of
beneficiaries to to come up with that
estimate i don't it's been a while since
we looked at that
okay so it's impractical
to do what i'm trying to do which is to
find a way to do a carve out that
addresses the greatest needs because
they're all of equal needs and and we
have the 209b or whatever that sort of
would
rope us into doing all or nothing
i mean it gives us flexibility elsewhere
but in this particular instance it does
require us to cover
certain fragile groups that are disabled
the blind
representative weiler
thank you mr chairman
mr lipman while we're
slightly different subject but i know
you track a lot of numbers
so what we're talking about hhs and
spending i'm curious have you any idea
how much you're going to lapse
um
i think i need to
to consult with karen rounds to give you
a number on that i think our concern
honestly in terms of the medicaid budget
at this point is
you know just
the beginning of this month
the
feds
issued what the unwind guidance is and
so we've been getting enhanced fmap the
extra 6.2 percent
what's going to end up happening though
is on the latest guidance saying that
you could only
disenroll up to
those people who aren't eligible up to
one-ninth of your enrollment which means
we're gonna probably for example if it
ends
the middle of july we could start this
enrollments beginning august 1st
the enhanced death map is going to end
in september 30th and then we're going
to have a tale of a number of months
where we're still going to be working to
get the enrollment down
and that's where
i think we're concerned about the
adequacy of what we have today it looks
great but
in terms of how long it actually takes
to to bring the enrollment back to you
know the pre
pandemic level we we we think we're
going to get there by
you know april at least
and that
but we're concerned about whether there
is a lapse in the medicaid spend itself
because of that well there's still a lot
of vacancies in employment right yes and
that's what that's where i think i need
karen to okay to opine let mr ripple
know so he can inform us thank you sure
yeah so
this is leaning towards us waiting until
monday to take a vote anyways so we've
got some time to get that data and i i
noticed that representative walner uh is
a co-sponsor so i should have been
asking her to explain this whole thing
to us
no mr snaken snow is the expert in this
one thank you
all right are
do we have any more questions from the
committee members
i'm not seeing any um mr lipman oh wait
a second go ahead just getting back to
that issue of carve out um
how cumbersome would it be to even do
the identification of sort of what
they're i mean because most people don't
have a single diagnosis um how
cumbersome would it be to say we're
going to carve out treating only this
particular
issue and actually would it be if you
were eligible via
um having severe mental illness would
that enable you to get coverage for all
your other medical things so it's either
you know you have severe mental illness
you have your cover for everything if
you don't you're not covered for
anything or would it be selectively only
covering their mental illness how
cumbersome would it be to make those
determinations
so so to save time i've withdrawn the
idea on the carve out it's not practical
do you still want the answer
no i think because i yeah no i don't
need it then because for that and play
not in play
yeah i i i i
explored it and it doesn't seem to be
feasible so
um
okay so mr lipman representative snow
what what do you want to say about this
bill that you haven't had a chance yet
to say i cut you off at one point
representatives now
i didn't mean to cut you off i was going
to i cut you off i'm apologizing
anyway no i i i just
you feel like
i guess you can sense my sense of
urgency about getting something done
you know over the many years i've worked
in this thing i've literally interacted
with
thousands of people that have this
severe
problem in life with
ongoing and persistent mental illness
and i'm i'm
sympathetic to their struggle and i
would i would do anything i think to try
to find a way to make their life a
little bit easier
and not having to make them struggle
about documenting how much service
they've gotten at the beginning of the
month making sure that we have them i
think some of the steps that the state's
taken by getting a third of the people
that are presently in
in and out
into the regular medicaid program is a
huge step in the right direction
it is going to cost a little bit
but
what it costs the state
is automatically going to reduce the
amount of bad debt the non-profit
organizations that contract with the
state to provide service to these
individuals come down so that there is a
trade and keeping in in
in mind the fact
that that changes
we lose all of it you only have to put
in
half of it if you follow
the logic so i just hope we can i would
love to have this committee be creative
if you can only find some way
to move this whole thing ahead just a
little bit i'd rather see it for
everybody
the way it was originally intended so
people with kidney disease
copd diabetes other illnesses would have
and quite clearly among the people that
i work with a lot of them especially the
older people that have been around for a
long time
they have very complicated situations
with physical problems which compound
the kind of medical problems as you can
imagine
makes them much more difficult to manage
so
i i hope we can find some way in the
very near future
i would be very disappointed if this
if the suspension could not be lifted
during the second year of this biennium
but i certainly hope
that the scheduled implementation of
this beginning july 1st 2023
will take place
as it was supposed to
is that something that
do i understand you to be saying that if
we change the effective date the act
shall be take effect upon passage if we
change that the act will take effect
1 july
well
to my way of thinking the law is on the
books now
and it should be funded within it was
suspended for this biennium
the additional funding was suspended for
this biennium but not beyond this
biennium so my assumption is that unless
some other action is taken
you know to shoot this idea down it
would automatically take effect in july
all right uh the law is on the books in
other words yeah mr mr lippman so
so
we get a 50 50 match on this i
understand so so that means
if if the state's going to put in 5.37
the feds are going to put in that much
so we're talking ab approximately 10.7
million dollars total
ultimately who is the recipient of that
money
will that 10.7 basically flow almost
what would happen is be treated just
like any other insurance premium might
be we would pay the capitation rate to
the mco and the mco would pay the
expenses as they're incurred whether
they be at a mental health center or
what have you um
so it
it would flow the normal way that we
covered generally most of the medicaid
population but that's that's for the
people
all right so so give me give me an idea
of what that is does that mean 90 will
go directly to our providers
so
the minimum under our statute
in general in the whole program is the
minimum of 85 percent is by law has to
be spent on medical
services
um there's a margin for a one and a half
percent margin allowed for uh profit
built into the rates um there's a
premium tax which
is two percent and then the balance to
85 is administration
cost
one one argument i've heard and i'm just
curious how you respond to it is that
the state
when we mandated that
the community health centers had to
provide mental health care
that we also agreed that um
we since we were given them a burden
that we would pay 80 percent of their
costs you know without documentation of
volume
um
and that because we're already paying 80
of their expenses
this bad debt although it sounds
significant in effect is not all that
dramatic because we've already covered
80 percent of their expenses would you
or can you does that sound familiar
it doesn't honestly but
it could it could ben before my time but
i think um
the way that mental health centers
receive a large portion of that money is
through a capitation a sub-capitation
arrangement that they have with the mc
managed care organizations
and so
um
there
there's a portion that they get fifa
the
i don't have a an answer to the 80
percent
issue that you you mentioned um
but you know i think that
the
financial
position of the
the managed care organizations i mean
excuse me the mental health centers is
really that
we're going to provide this service
you're just
because of you haven't raised the income
limits since 19
whatever the date was that we're having
to absorb that that doesn't seem fair to
the clients that we serve or to or to us
i think that's
what the argument basically boils down
to and i i think the the continuity of
knowing that you have
coverage and you're not having to worry
whether you're in and out is
probably um therapeutically beneficial
all right thank you it was a tough
question you did it
pretty well given that i probably was
making things up there so
representative snow i think we also need
to keep in mind we're talking about two
different groups of people you talked
about the 80 and so forth that's for the
people who are in the regular medicaid
program
under this jurisdiction of one of those
three managed care companies that run it
the people under the
in and out program
would not be considered that way because
there is the only reimbursement that we
get
is the fee for service fee which is the
same fee that everybody else pays we
don't raise the fees on them it's the
same fee
we only collect those fees once that
spend down
has been met
and
that's what i'm trying to seek to avoid
and that's what adds up to that
uh
to that debt
which is pretty substantial
all right i
i go ahead mr lemon
try to respect where you were going with
this originally if you mind i could ask
don landry to a question here because
i'm wondering if there is a
um well we can't
rule out the the blind disable the
the fragile
i just want to confirm with her if i
could
so the question i want to ask don in
well there are these groups that we
have to include which groups could we
not include is there are there any in
hi good afternoon my name is don landry
i'm a medicaid policy administrator with
the department
so it's it's called a medically needy
group
um generally speaking medically needy is
an option for states and right now the
only
groups we could potentially eliminate
would be for like pregnant women and
children but i would not
say a hundred percent for children
because i do believe we still have
maintenance of effort requirements for
kids
um
other than that we do have to have the
spend down program for the age blind and
disabled
thanks
all right so i
want to reaffirm that i am not
yeah
i i think i think we're full i i think
we've heard everything uh you know i
part of um the reason i've had so many
questions i i i just was unfamiliar with
this program and i i still feel like i
pretty much am
um
i think if i were to summarize what
we're talking about doing is we're
trying to make up for 30 years of
holding
eligibility levels flat
and that just by recognizing some
inflationary effect
some not all
it in effect would increase our costs uh
at the state level for by about 5.3
million
doubled if you include the federal money
of which about 85 will flow to our
network
so
um so these are these are vital
resources needed for a major component
of our entire um
network of community health systems so
um
i i just need to go back to my boss and
her boss and and find out
you know because the governor's going
through a process right he's got this
program where he's looking at
all the things he wants to spend some of
the excess revenue on and i just want to
see where this program racks and stacks
in the governor's vision and to what
extent that we would need to you know
negotiate something there so i'll try to
get that done by monday which is not
easy given we have three session days
so if maybe the governor will just come
yeah
all right all right so if uh no oh
representative snow i was just trying to
wrap up
i just
i just wanted to thank you for your
patience and listening to what we had to
say
and i hope somehow between us we can
come up with some kind of a solution to
meet the needs of this very needy group
thank you all right all right thank you
so with that
uh i'm going to close the hearing on uh
hp 1526
and uh i want to open up what what might
be a relatively short conversation on
1531.
representative knurk are you prepared to
talk to this without a coincidence
actually this one did not come to our
committee and so i am no more familiar
with this than anybody else is okay so
so mr ripple i'm i'm gonna say what i
think is true and then i want you to
correct me and extend it to the extent
i think that
what all this got amended to doing
was repealing
um
two
parts of the commissions that we had
established
and although in the original bill is
introduced there there was a fiscal note
that's about 150 000. when we go to just
these repeals
i i think there is probably no fiscal
impact
uh and
and actually this may be one of those
negative things if we don't
have a commission then
maybe we actually save some money
so i i'm thinking that if it's a
negative number or a zero number on the
on the fiscal impact this is one that we
would probably just
um
do a formality and otping it next monday
mr ripple how'd i do how would you
correct or extend what i said uh i think
it's true if you've seen the revised
fiscal note that i think we
put out over the weekend it states
there's no fiscal impact to the bill as
amended
uh mr representative irv
thank you i did speak with
representative rice
and yes your your presentation was
accurate
there's actually another side to this
and that is that this even though these
commissions themselves are being
eliminated in statute they're actually
being incorporated into
other commissions that already exist for
these purposes and apparently that's
coming through in the senate bill so i
agree with your otp
indication
so the military way of thinking about
that is they're just reassigning the
mission to other existing organizations
uh okay
very good
so um
so i laid out a proposal that we vote on
this on monday it should be an easy vote
or really just a courtesy to
representative rogers
or we could vote on it now would would
representative
wallner or representative canark should
all right um
all right we'll we will defer a vote on
this until monday
and there's no amendments or anything so
um
okay so before i adjourn for the day are
there any uh
you know
words for the good of the cause did
did you did
anything did we forget anything
mr clerk did do i need to ask for
anything before we go it's we're it's
not blurb time yet blurb assignments are
the ones i missed will do monday anyway
yeah so we're actually we're going to
put everything we did today
on monday because we didn't get a good
vote on those
plus i think it was 1647 that um
division one slid to us
that
that that needs to be added so
technically we've got we picked up
another bill
and and that one we don't know anything
about so i'm going to do that last so
that we can run through the the first
ones uh fairly quickly and then spend
are we done okay so with that i
adjourned today's work session on
you